[Musique]
bonjour ou rebonjour à tous et bienvenue
à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent sur SCP
pour cette journée passionnante sous le
signe du couple franco-allemand nous
sommes ensemble jusqu'à 18h pour vivre
en direct les cérémonies d'anniversaire
des 60 ans du traité de l'Élysée le
traité de réconciliation entre la France
et l'Allemagne alors après les discours
de la Sorbonne ce matin avec le discours
de la Souls le président le chancelier
allemand et le président français
Emmanuel Macron place à l'Assemblée
nationale et place au parlementaire ou
députés français et députés allemands
vont pouvoir échanger notamment avec
leurs deux présidentes puisque ce sont
deux femmes vous le savez pour tous ceux
qui nous suivent depuis ce matin avec
moi 4 invités pour parler à la fois de
ce qui s'est dit ce matin et pour se
projeter sur cet après-midi Pascal
Johanna bonjour et merci d'être fidèle à
la Chaîne Parlementaire vous êtes la
directrice générale de la Fondation
Robert Schuman bonjour Hélène milliard
Delacroix bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation professeur à la
Sorbonne dont vous sortez à l'instant
vous avez écouté les discours des deux
dirigeants vous êtes une grande
spécialiste de l'Allemagne contemporaine
et puis deux parlementaires à
parlementaires français Frédéric valait
tout bonjour merci d'être avec nous
député horizons de Cernay
orn bonjour à vous un Français
absolument fluide on aimerait en dire
autant de nos parlementaires vous êtes
député allemand du SPD le Parti
socialiste allemand qui a gagné en
partie la coalition avec Olaf schollz au
pouvoir alors nous sommes également en
duplex avec Marco pommier et avec
Valérie Brochard pour vivre en direct et
bien les arrivées des députés avant
qu'ils ne prennent la parole dans
l'hémicycle Marco quel est quel est le
programme comment ça va se passer alors
tout à l'heure et bien Myriam les
députés français et allemands ont
rendez-vous dans 30 minutes dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale et
d'ailleurs petite anecdote pour les
députés allemands un peu perdu dans les
couloirs du Palais Bourbon et bien
l'assemblée a mis en place des panneaux
pour où se trouvait l'hémicycle alors
figurez-vous que en allemand ça s'écrit
plénard ça se dit plaignar sale à
l'hémicycle alors désolé pour pour la
prononciation mais alors au programme
cet après-midi une séance parlementaire
franco-allemande présidé dans un premier
temps pariel présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale puis par barbelbass présidente
du buntenstag allemand les groupes
politiques qui composent les deux
assemblées en fait vont intervenir avant
une déclaration commune et puis pour
clôturer cette journée en l'honneur de
l'amitié franco-allemande des échanges
sont prévus entre des jeunes Allemands
des jeunes Français avec El Braun Pivet
et barbelbass ce sera aux alentours de
17h15 17h30 merci Marco et puis on va
revenir très vite au micro de Valérie
Brochard avec les premiers députés
français et allemand qui qui arrivent
d'abord revenons sur cette matinée
madame meunière Delacroix vous étiez
donc à la à la Sorbonne pas d'annonce
concrètes ça on peut le dire une vraie
célébration de l'amitié Franco une
relance en tout cas dans les dans les
mots dans la volonté politique du moteur
franco-allemand mais on est un peu sur
sa fin ce matin on s'attendait à un peu
plus sur des politiques concrètes alors
c'est sûr qu'on avait à faire à une
commémoration et d'abord avec des
hommages rendus à juste titre aux
initiateurs avant même la signature du
traité de l'Élysée rendu au
parlementaire qui se réunissent et qui
sait faire avancer converger les lois
hommage rendu aux citoyens et citoyennes
de base qui font le maillage
franco-allemand et ça c'était bien de
l'avoir fait parce que si on ne l'avait
pas fait vous rendez compte ça aurait
été vraiment honteux il y a eu des
choses assez attendues bien évidemment
l'amitié la proximité les images alors
après on ne le président français a osé
les jumeaux de l'histoire et de destins
bon pourquoi pas tout cela tenait d'une
tradition moi j'aurais tendance à dire
que les deux les quatre discours que
nous avons entendus étaient tous
différents
les Français étaient très français et
les discours Allemands étaient très
allemands alors ça veut dire quoi
il y a un mot en allemand qui est Harley
c'est à dire qu'en allemand les discours
allemands je trouve parler était concret
parler des choses
sans grande envolée et la partie
française alors ça va encore conforter
les préjugés les pensées toutes faites
qu'on est sur la France c'est-à-dire en
faisant parlant plus de sentiment
d'émotions de lyrisme des très belles
envolées aussi et je pense que c'est
important moi ce que j'ai relevé c'était
que des deux côtés on a parlé de la
volonté
le président Macron a plus parlé
d'audace de fidélité à l'audace des
précurseurs mais bon à part c'est c'est
une conférence de presse à l'Élysée aux
alentours de 17h évidemment les
journalistes vont pouvoir poser des
questions et notamment sur la guerre en
Ukraine à Amazon qu'avez-vous lui dire
votre chancelier précisément quand il a
dit soutien d'effectible à l'Ukraine
soutient militaire il a même parlé des
blindés mais il est resté assez général
voire ambigu sur la question des
charléopards attendus plus qu'attendu
par les Ukrainiens les chars allemands
je pense que ce que les chancelier
atteignaient à dire c'est que il y a un
truc qui a été très clair derrière le
début de la guerre c'est que la France
et l'Allemagne reste solidaire avec
l'Ukraine d'ailleurs l'Allemagne a
toujours supporté l'Ukraine même des
gens avant la guerre par de nombreux
moyens que ce soit par l'échelle
financière que ce soit par depuis la
guerre aussi par l'échelle humanitaire
et tout ce qui concerne les questions de
sécurité et les questions de support
militaire là je pense aussi que on va
continuer à supporter l'Ukraine ça je
pense que c'est clair plus qu'avant en
termes de soutien militaire
je pense que ce qu'on a fait aussi en
tant qu'Allemagne pendant ces dernières
mois pendant ces derniers mois c'était
un site une bande c'est un site internet
à la langue allemande difficilement
produisit c'est le changement d'époque
c'est ça par rapport à la doctrine
stratégique exactement et je pense que
c'est ce que les chancelier a laissé
aussi entendre ce matin c'est que je
vais pas dire que on a trouvé un accord
mais je reste très très optimiste que ce
support pour l'Ukraine va continuer un
premier député celle des quatre colonnes
et je fais circuler la parole en plateau
Valérie Brocha vous êtes aux côtés du
député communiste Nicolas sont su
absolument Myriam monsieur sangsue
bonjour
vous allez vous exprimer dans quelques
instants dans l'hémicycle quel est le
message que vous voulez faire passer le
message c'est que la paix se construit
on a mis 60 ans à construire une paix
durable entre la France et l'Allemagne
mais aussi on voit que la paix se
construit aussi sur des basses scènes
c'est-à-dire sur une économie qui qui ne
met pas la concurrence entre les peuples
qui n'aimaient pas forcément la finance
à l'honneur et aujourd'hui on voit que
partout en Europe les nationalismes
gagnent et ça c'est c'est
malheureusement pour voyeur de crise et
de conflits et il me semble qu'il
faudrait orienter les robes dans ce
cadre et à partir de là arrêtez avec
l'Europe des marchés et des marchands et
aller vers une Europe sociale je crois
que ce serait le meilleur moyen pour
assurer la paix elle signifie quoi
exactement cette journée pour vous cette
journée elle signifie d'abord une amitié
entre nos deux peuples vous savez j'ai
été maire d'une ville pendant pendant 14
ans et nous avons deux jumelages avec
deux villes allemandes on a toujours
fait travailler ces jumelages de manière
extrêmement intéressante avec les jeunes
avec la culture avec le sport donc voilà
on a avec nos amis allemands comme
disait le poète c'est à dire la douce
loi des hommes c'est de transformer les
ennemis en frères et bien voilà on a
réussi à faire en sorte qu'on transforme
nos ennemis frère mais aujourd'hui je
crois que il y a un autre sujet qui est
plus global c'est-à-dire qu'elle monte
nous voulons si c'est le monde de Davos
que l'on a vu la semaine dernière je
crois que malheureusement on va vers des
conflits et on voit que les
nationalismes montrent on voit certains
gouvernements qui en Europe ont fait on
fait on pencher vers vers le
nationalisme voir le fascisme et
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui nous guette
c'était le maire de Vierzon si je me
trompe pas merci merci beaucoup monsieur
sangsue Merci à VOUS Valérie Brochard la
question du nationalisme la question de
la guerre elle est évidemment
omniprésente même voilà dans toutes les
têtes même s'il s'agit de célébrer les
60 ans du traité de l'Elysée est-ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler au fond ce que
c'est parce que les jeunes ne
connaissent pas ce traité ils
connaissent les grands traités qu'on
apprend dans l'histoire de la
construction européenne mais moins celui
de l'Élysée d'abord c'est pas un traité
de la construction européenne c'est à
traiter bilatéral entre la France
absolument mais la réconciliation franco
allemande contrairement à ce qu'a dit
Monsieur sangsue à l'instant elle date
pas de 1963 la 2950 quand on a fait la
première communauté européenne déjà avec
le chancelier Adenauer et Robert Schuman
et ses 6 états fondateurs qui ont dit
plus jamais ça après cinq ans seulement
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale donc on
n'a pas 60 ans d'amitié franco-allemande
on a 73 et en effet il y a ce traité
bilatéral alors ce serait bilatéral il
vient renforcer une
une relation qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ça
va faire un jour au 25 autres évidemment
puisqu'on est 27 dans l'Union européenne
mais quand la France et l'Allemagne
s'entendent bien ça une un débouché
favorable sur l'Union européenne qu'on
se souvienne dans la crise covid le plan
de relance d'abord la chancelière et le
président français et puis après c'est
en effet une décision européenne et une
collective parce que ça reste les deux
plus grosses économies d'Europe
qu'on le veuille ou non encore par la
termes de la population par le terme du
PIB parce qu'en effet c'est avec eux
qu'on a fait la guerre en 70-14 et en 39
faut bien le rappeler donc en effet la
PC quelque chose d'autant plus que
Schumann à donneurs et des hommes de la
frontière donc voilà mais c'est fragile
et toutes ces nouvelles j'allais dire
équipage donc là on a un nouvel équipage
parce que le chancelier Scholl c'est là
depuis un an grosso modo de moi
acteurs et le président
le le chanceux les choses et dans une
coalition qu'on n'a jamais vu en
Allemagne c'est pas faire en France mais
c'est parce qu'on avait toujours une
coalition à deux parties plus on a une
commission à trois parties et on voit
bien que c'est un peu plus compliqué
pour avoir l'ensemble d'une décision
notamment sur le crâne je pense en effet
que tous les parties de la coalition
sont favorables à soutenir l'Ukraine
mais pas forcément à des degrés d'hiver
ce qui empêche son sujet parce que tout
était créé à la virgule près dans une
coalition en Allemagne contrairement à
ce qu'on ferait en France et que donc ça
c'est plus difficile mais on attend en
effet dans cette période peut-être ou
c'est plus difficile pour l'Ukraine par
rapport à la Russie d'avoir une décision
tout de suite
franco-allemande et européenne pour
peut-être éviter que la guerre ne dure
plus longtemps qu'elle est prévue
polonais qui ont des chars léopards eux
aimeraient les donner alors qu'ils
doivent avoir normalement la sentiment
de l'Allemagne mais ils ont dit mais on
va pas attendre censé tant donc
dépêchez-vous oui ça il faut expliquer
parce que les chars Léopards ont été
vendus par l'Allemagne au Polonais mais
conditionné pour les livrer à l'Ukraine
à l'accord des Allemands Frédéric valait
tout on célèbre cette amitié en grande
pompe avec force symbole sourire et
forte expression également mais pourtant
cette relation elle va moins bien
crise passion certains disent il y a pas
mal de points de désaccord sur l'énergie
sur la question de la défense sur la
question commerciale aussi oui bien sûr
il y a des questions qui sont
plaignantes qui sont sans doute
difficile mais enfin on sort pas de 60
ans d'amour et d'eau fraîche comme on
dit en France et on sort pas d'une
relation qui pendant 60 ans a été
totalement fluide apaisée elle a eu des
hauts elle a eu des bas elle a eu des
moments forts elle a eu des moments de
stagnation il y a eu des moments
symboliques la mare de vous interroge
vous redonne la parole dans un instant
mais Marco pommier à son micro à les
deux présidentes du Bundestag et de
l'Assemblée nationale on vous écoute oui
les deux présidentes sont avec nous
myriam a Yaël brune pivée une
coprésidence pour cette séance de
conseils des de conseils franco-allemand
alors pour cette séance particulière
pour l'amitié pour l'amitié
franco-allemand c'est inédit alors oui
c'est inédit ce qui est inédit déjà
c'est de réunir le Bundestag et
l'Assemblée nationale au sein de
l'hémicycle de faire vraiment une séance
conjointe et effectivement c'est avec un
grand plaisir que je céderais une partie
de la présidence à berberle parce que
c'est vraiment le signe de notre amitié
et des liens de plus en plus fructueux
que nous voulons nouer ensemble et je
pense que qu'elle soit assise un instant
au perchoir c'est un c'est un beau
signal que nous envoyons alors pendant
que vous serez dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale il y aura un
conseil des ministres franco-allemand à
l'Élysée qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
ce conseil des ministres franco-allemand
[Musique]
et alors comme je ne parle pas
parfaitement l'allemand on va avoir la
traduction avec Monsieur dites-nous
alors j'attends du Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand qu'il donne un élan et
confirme cette amitié franco-allemande
mais aussi un élan pour l'Union
européenne de manière générale et je
suis très optimiste que les ministres
dans ce format feront avancer cette
amitié et apporteront des résultats
concrets merci beaucoup merci à vous
Mesdames et bonne séance merci et merci
beaucoup vous à vous Marco pommier je
vous redonne la parole Frédéric valétou
une journée comme celle-là on a
l'impression que tout va pour le mieux
entre la France et l'Allemagne est-ce
que c'est vraiment le cas alors je
disais que donc 60 ans de relation s'il
y a eu des hauts et des bas et que on a
toujours eu des moments de crispation ou
l'un ou l'autre pays s'interrogeait
parfois sur son propre modèle et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des questions sur
le l'énergie qui interroge l'Allemagne
la stratégie les sur la géopolitique sur
le réarmement enfin voilà il y a des
questions de fond que que prend ce pays
d'autres qui nous aussi traversent notre
pays donc de ce point de vue là non je
parle pas de crise je pense que
justement la force des moments
symboliques c'est que aussi il reste
dans l'histoire et que peut-être que
l'image de cet après-midi comme celle de
ce matin avec tous les parlementaires
qui vont être dans l'hémicy comme les
deux présidents les deux chefs de l'État
côte à côte à la Sorbonne et bien vont
peut-être aussi survivre à ces moments
de crise c'est-à-dire on se souvient je
mais vous m'avez interrompu pour une
très bonne raison donc il y a pas de
sujet mais je parlais de la main dans la
main d'elmut Cole et de François
Mitterrand cette image a survécu on sait
même plus finalement quand elle a été
prise c'était la fin des années 80 bon
elle a elle elle a signifié beaucoup de
choses pour les plus anciens comme pour
les plus jeunes de chacun nos deux pays
donc peut-être que des photos de cet
après-midi vont aussi montrer à des des
choses très fortes qui survivront et les
crises faut pas les minorer je pense que
la force aussi de la relation entre la
France et l'Allemagne aujourd'hui en
tous les cas c'est qu'elles sont
capables de regarder de manière un peu
froide les difficultés en essayant le
plus possible et quand on a 60 ans
derrière soi peut-être qu'on est encore
plus motivé pour le faire de trouver des
solutions à chacun des sujets vous êtes
à l'Assemblée nationale ici on est en
cinquième république même s'il y a une
nouvelle donne politique dans
l'hémicycle qui fait trouva davantage
chercher des compromis pour trouver des
majorités vous au bout de tag c'est
votre culture de depuis toujours que peu
le franco-allemand au niveau
parlementaire est-ce que c'est vraiment
un élément moteur
[Musique]
allemand et surtout des relations entre
les deux pays je tiens je pense qu'il
est important aussi
de mentionner le fait que les parlements
les deux parlements jouent un rôle très
très important
aussi comme la société comme les deux
sociétés jouent un très très rôle très
très important dans ce groupe
franco-allemand concernant tout ce qui
est parlementaire bien sûr qu'en
Allemagne on a une autre culture
parlementaire on a plutôt un parlement
qui est un peu plus qui a plus de
pouvoir qui pousse un peu plus son
gouvernement
apprendre c'est des décisions quand je
pense que si les choses sont un peu
bloquées à l'échelle ministérielle on
voit un peu que entre les deux
gouvernements certaines décisions peut
prendre un peu plus de temps je pense
que par l'Assemblée Franco
franco-allemande on a notre possibilité
de mettre les sujets clés les sujets
très par exemple
et peut-être que je peux revenir ce que
vous aviez dit tout à l'heure je pense
que il est très très important de
regarder le couple franco-allemand dans
le moment dans lequel on se trouve en ce
moment nous parlons de d'avancer un peu
plus en matière de collaboration nous
parlons du moteur franco-allemand qui
est important pour renouveler l'Europe
c'est pas c'est pas le quotidien on vit
vraiment une sainte Band et je pense que
quand on est dans une situation comme ça
il est aussi très très important de
savoir que chaque pays chaque société
chaque gouvernement vient avec de
différentes perceptions de différentes
intérêts et je trouve ça tout à fait
logique que parfois ça prend un peu plus
de temps mais je suis très très persuadé
quand un certain moment va se mettre
ensemble on va trouver une très très
bonne solution et comme le président et
le chanceux l'ont dit ce matin quand le
couple franco-allemand trouve une
position
je pense que la possibilité que que
cette solution soit bonne poteau de
l'Europe est très très heureux
à quel moment on est précisément de la
relation puis je vous redonne la parole
juste après parce que les dossiers de
crispation sont très nombreux alors vous
savez que quand on est sur le temps
présent et extrêmement difficile de
d'identifier la dimension historique je
pense que ça a été dit ce matin il y a
une dimension historique qui est
incontestable en raison du changement
d'époque à signifier pas seulement pour
l'Allemagne mais pour l'ensemble de
l'Europe et pour notre conception de
notre continent
contient du 24 février avec l'attaque de
l'Ukraine par par la Russie donc par
définition vous avez parfaitement raison
ce ce qui est fait maintenant et ce qui
va être décidé maintenant doit être
marquant l'Allemagne a été
particulièrement déstabilisé par oui en
guerre oui mais c'était aussi logique
parce que un certain nombre de
d'éléments fondateurs ou fondamentaux
dans l'équilibre du modèle allemand en
matière énergétique en matière de
commerce extérieure et en matière disons
de défense ou de noms
beaucoup de choses enfin beaucoup de
certitudes ont été absolument renversés
donc ce que je voudrais peut-être un
tout petit peu ajouter c'est que le mot
compromis que vous avez utilisé qui est
caractéristique de la démocratie et de
la pratique de la du mode de trouver des
décisions en Allemagne est aussi
fondamentale dans la coopération
franco-allemande depuis le début alors
vous avez parfaitement raison de dire
que on a un regard très prospectif comme
si c'était un monde absolument idéal non
il ne faut pas être naïf c'est une
histoire qui a toujours été compliquée
parce que ou deux pays ont toujours été
très différents moi ce qui m'a quand
même un peu frappé ce matin dans le
discours du chancelier Scholtz c'est
qu'il a évoqué les grandes époques le
problème c'est qu'il s'est arrêté à
Helmut call et François Mitterrand alors
c'était le 24 septembre 22 septembre
1984 c'est passé beaucoup de choses
depuis voilà alors je me suis interrogée
sur est-ce que c'est une histoire qui
s'est terminée avec la réunification et
il a plomb il a sauté dans le temps
présent or je pense que ce qui est
important c'est de comprendre que nous
fêtons 60e anniversaire mais nous
souhaitons aussi 60 ans d'accumulation
de savoir-faire de difficultés de
recherche de compromis et d'arriver à
trouver des moyens termes en parlant
clairement et si on a vraiment un effort
à faire par rapport à la petite crise
qu'on a eu à l'automne c'est par les
Clermont s'informer ne jamais se prendre
au dépourvu
je crois qu'il est aussi important de
souligner tout à l'heure vous parliez
effectivement de la relation entre les
chefs d'État
de la relation entre les parlements mais
faut voir que cette amitié également ce
lien franco-allemand il est à tous les
étages de la société ça a été rapidement
dit mais il y a 2500 jumelages qui
existent 2500 villes allemandes qui sont
jumelles 2500 villes françaises et c'est
tous les jours des gens qui traversent
la frontière des clubs des chorales des
pour parler pour échanger pour se
connaître donc c'est une relation qui
n'est pas qu'une relation d'État ni
politique dans la société civile au plus
près du terrain et pourtant on parle de
moins en moins français en Allemagne et
on parle de moins en moins allemand en
France vous habitez finalement qui parle
très bien français
qui montre par exemple la Brigade
franco-allemande qui existe une un
premier exemple de défense en commun qui
n'est pas vraiment très puissante mais
il ne se parle qu'en anglais il y a
encore beaucoup d'efforts à faire c'est
vrai qu'on a une diminution très forte
de la pratique de l'allemand en France
ça Hélène pourrait en parler mieux que
moi et peut-être en Allemagne on a aussi
peut-être un et que l'anglais est devenu
une langue plus facile parce que c'est
vrai que la grammaire française et la
allemande sont un peu plus compliquées
que la grammaire anglaise mais ceci
étant dit à côté des jumelages
yallophages il y a un certain nombre de
choses que vous avez dites mais c'est
surtout la responsabilité des chefs
d'État de gouvernement à un momenté de
surpasser un petit peu les difficultés
on voit bien qu'en effet la crise en
Ukraine à sérieusement fait tanguer les
certitudes allemandes économiques
industriels militaire je rappelle qu'en
effet l'armée allemande est une armée
parlementaire donc voilà donc et donc on
a en effet un nouveau un changement
d'époque mais il faut qu'on réussisse ce
changement d'époque et donc la
responsabilité c'est pas que Emmanuel
Macron ou Scholl c'est l'un qui sera
responsable il faut que les deux
arrivent à surpasser là réussir ce
changement
l'image en effet forte mais il y a eu
des moments où ça sérieusement tendu
entre les deux donc en effet il faut que
ce moment qui n'est pas très agréable
cesse le plus tôt possible à la fois
pour le bien de l'Europe parce que je
redis qu'en effet quand la France et
l'Allemagne s'entendent il y a une
conséquence européenne et peut-être pour
le bien de l'Ukraine et de la longévité
de la crise en Ukraine si on a en effet
une réponse assez rapide sur les
attentes de l'Ukraine pour la soutenir
comme on s'y engage tous depuis et
maintenant pratiquement un an pour qu'en
effet on aide vraiment l'Ukraine avec en
effet un équipement qui devient de plus
en plus lourd je sais bien que les
Allemands sont très rétifs sur toutes
ces questions mais peut-être que le
Bundes tag autorise Monsieur que les Léa
va voir aille en Ukraine puisque ça sera
une décision du monde de stag à la fin
réponse Armand Zorn c'est vrai qu'elle
est très attendue cette décision et je
pense qu'à un certain moment
je pense que tout doit être on doit
mettre tout sur la table et compris ce
qui est l'accord au pays de l'Est pour
livrer les Léopards à l'Ukraine je suis
d'accord on doit discuter de ça aussi
mais ce que je trouve à même ce qui
n'est pas honnête dans ce débat c'est
que j'observe ça depuis le début de la
guerre c'est qu'à chaque fois il y a un
symbole qui est discuté comme si c'était
ça qui allait changer complètement la
guerre je me souviens le 24 le 24
février quelques quelques semaines après
le déclenchement de la guerre on parlait
c'est quand même un tournant on parlait
on parlait de Swift on parlait de des
sanctions
après c'est venu après de ça on parlait
des des armes tout simplement je suis
d'accord on doit mettre tous sur la
table mais je pense qu'on doit quand
même aussi un peu quitter ce point de
vue on fait comme si ça jette d'un arbre
ou alors d'une sanction ou alors d'une
mesure qui va complètement changer cette
guerre mais sinon
j'entends non honnêteté honnêteté et
sincérité dans ce débat mais je pense
que tout est Sud j'attends que bientôt
il y aura une décision quelques minutes
avant de rejoindre l'hémicycle Marco
pommier vous êtes avec un député député
de Paris député Renaissance Sylvain
Maillard oui Myriam Sylvain Maillard
vous êtes aussi président du groupe
d'amitié franco-allemand à l'Assemblée
qu'est-ce qu'elle signifie cette journée
pour vous nous c'est une journée
extrêmement importante d'abord pour
rappeler toute la journée l'amitié
France Allemagne construite depuis 60
ans plus que 60 ans mais officialisé
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale ça fait
60 ans maintenant et de faire des
contacts de nouer des contacts parfois
avec nos homologues allemands qui sont
ici avec nous qui vont être dans
l'hémicycle dans quelques minutes je
crois que c'est relation là sont très
importantes et pour moi qui préside
qu'il a la chance de présider ce groupe
d'amitié
franco-allemand avec nos parlementaires
allemands c'est le l'occasion de
construire des relations et qu'on va
nourrir tout au long de notre mandat
alors tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle
vous allez prendre la parole qu'est-ce
que vous allez dire à vos collègues
allemands et français d'abord rappeler
mon amitié notre amitié pour l'Allemagne
moi j'ai une histoire avec l'Allemagne
j'ai eu la chance d'être étudiant là-bas
j'ai eu la chance d'y travailler pendant
plusieurs années et donc de maîtriser
l'allemand je crois que c'est aussi une
vraie chance de bien connaître
l'Allemagne et de rappeler l'amitié
profonde que nous avons entre nos deux
pays dire aussi que cette amitié doit
nous permettre de nous construire de
construire sur les les difficultés que
nous avons à l'heure actuelle nous
parlions tout à l'heure avec Michael
link par exemple du FDP nos difficultés
sur l'énergie comment nous voyons aussi
l'évolution la guerre en Ukraine comment
faire pour aider les Ukrainiens il y a
des points très importants et puis aussi
faire face aux grands grands enjeux dont
on ne parle finalement assez peu et le
grand des grands enjeux en Allemagne
c'est la démographie comment faire pour
aider et être aux côtés de nos amis
allemands merci beaucoup Sylvain Maya je
vous laisse rejoindre l'hémicycle pour
cette séance franco-allemande Merci à
VOUS Marco pommier avant que la garde
républicaine ne fasse retentir ces
tambours vous les voyez ils sont en
place avec l'arrivée des deux
présidentes dans l'hémicyclé avant de
vous laisser repartir messieurs les
parlementaires parce que c'est une
séance importante pour vous Frédéric
valettou vous vous pensez qu'on est à un
tournant de cette relation malgré les
points de crispation le couple Macron
Scholtz restera dans l'histoire
optimiste on a connu beaucoup de crises
on en a surmonté autant jusqu'à présent
donc il y a pas de raison que les
différents d'aujourd'hui
un peu avancer très concrètement
aujourd'hui sur la politique
industrielle la souveraineté économique
de défense et puis aussi peut-être sur
la vision de l'Union européenne telle
qu'on veut la partager après s'être
effectivement c'est arrivé de de ce choc
de la guerre sur le continent sans doute
ça va faire bouger les lignes aussi sur
ce qu'on veut mettre dans l'Union
européenne et l'Union européenne telle
qu'on vous voudrez la rêver dans les
prochaines années je pense qu'ils les
lignes vont bouger les lignes vont
bouger Hélène Millard de la Croix si
vous voulez regagner l'hémicycle je sais
que ça vous tient à cœur je vais vous
laisser librement merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup amusant et bravo pour votre
français vous le montrer l'exemple qu'il
a donc Hélène milliard Delacroix voilà
on est dans une forme de bon sentiment
il faut se le dire quand même alors que
leur de l'histoire est absolument
tragique sur la défense c'est une
question très attendue on saura pas
aujourd'hui si l'Allemagne à mon avis va
décider de livrer ses léopards ou pas
mais sur la question de défense commune
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui peut
encore avancer ou très honnêtement c'est
du point mort parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'Allemagne face à cette guerre est dans
l'OTAN c'est l'horizon indépassable de
sa défense je pense mais Pascal peut du
point de vue européen bien complété je
pense qu'il ne il y a des questions de
temporalité particulière en ce moment il
y a une accélération des priorités au
sens temporel et puis il y a pour autant
le maintien de priorité au sens
d'objectif et je crois que on est sur le
temps très très court et sur la décision
courte là et en effet il a été reproché
aux Allemands et à la bundesla de
commander tout de suite armée allemande
l'armée allemande pardon de commander
des avions F35 parce qu'ils étaient sur
l'étagère c'est-à-dire qu'ils étaient
immédiatement livrables et puis surtout
compatible avec le l'organisation et la
place de l'armée allemande dans l'OTAN
pour pouvoir notamment transporter des
bombes
la prière américaine pour autant cela ne
m'est pas empirie les ça ne doit pas le
faire et je pense qu'il y a un message
qui a quand même été envoyé début
décembre avec la visite de la première
minisborn en Allemagne cela ne doit pas
mettre en péril les projets qui avaient
en effet un peu patiné l'avion comme
l'avion du futur dans le programme scalf
qui correspondait aussi à des conflits
d'industriels ou des craintes de de
propriété intellectuelle de propriété
industrielles il faut il faut la bien
évidemment de la volonté mais surtout de
la vision à long terme ce métier à long
terme pour une défense un peu européenne
est-ce qu'on n'est pas tout seul en
France à vouloir la faire avancer ah non
je pense que les il y a il y a des
partenaires en Europe qui sont qui sont
prêts à le faire il y a des programmes
avec les Italiens avec les Espagnols etc
je pense que le mot qu'on a entendu ce
matin et c'était plutôt bien de
l'entendre de la bouche de la Scholl
c'est le mot souveraineté en parlant de
souveraineté européenne non pas le sens
où qui dérangeait les Allemands c'est à
dire au sens d'une autonomie qui
soutient qui voudrait dire une
émancipation par une autonomie par
rapport à l'OTAN mais une indépendance
quand même une souveraineté ça veut dire
être capable d'être dans le jeu et
d'être un acteur et de décider dans les
choix aussi de on est dans ces alliances
et il est pas question de sortir de
l'OTAN on ne peut pas demander ça aux
Allemands pour autant être capable
d'avoir des projets à moyen et à long
terme au niveau européen pour avoir une
souveraineté une capacité d'action et
d'être entendus c'est quand même le
message qui a été prononcé très
délicatement ce matin à la Sorbonne vous
partagez cette analyse il y a un petit
pas en avant sur les questions défenses
pour parler d'une seule voix
franco-allemand moi je vois toujours
vers à moitié plein plutôt que à moitié
vide donc on n'a pas la même culture on
ne sera pas toujours d'accord avec les
Allemands parce que nous sommes très
autonomes nous en matière de décision
c'est le président de la République qui
décide et puis nous avons une histoire
etc comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure les
Allemands une Armande une armée
parlementaire donc c'est le bundesta qui
décide de faire telle ou telle action on
a bien vu que le c'était au bundestal
que ça devait coincé etc donc on n'a pas
le même tempo mais il faut qu'on dépasse
ces différents pour avancer parce que
nous sommes un peu comme regarder comme
ceux qui ont la capacité d'impulser
quelque chose en Europe et on a dans la
guerre en Ukraine des partenaires
orientaux qui nous disent aujourd'hui
mais nous on connaît très bien le Russe
on a été annexécologue les Pays-Bas et
puis il y a la Pologne et puis les
autres parce qu'ils sont en première
ligne et si on veut conserver la
confiance et la crédibilité que nous
avons gagné pendant 60 ans faut pas
qu'on les déçoit donc on est polonais on
a aussi une responsabilité française de
pas seulement continuer à se batailler
entre nous mais à montrer que nous avons
compris et que les premières
incertitudes qui étaient à la fois
allemandes et françaises parce qu'on a
quand même eu aussi doivent être levés
pour que en effet tous ensemble on
avance parce que nos amis est européens
nous attendent et qui nous reprochent un
peu d'être frileux et d'être passé à
aller en avant et donc là on a une
responsabilité vous les entend les
tambours de la Garde Républicaine c'est
le signal d'un début de séance dans
l'hémicycle imminent et en évidemment
très particulière symbolique aujourd'hui
pour les 60 ans jour pour jour du traité
de la signature du traité de l'Élysée on
va les vivre ensemble ces images avec
l'arrivée vous le voyez
des présidentes c'est très important de
femmes là c'est la première fois
c'est la première fois effectivement
pour le perchoir à l'Assemblée nationale
il y a LeBron Pivet avec son homologue
du boule de stats
[Musique]
en Allemagne c'est tellement différent
ce voilà ce rituel est fait partie de la
culture de la République de la
République française et c'est très
impressionnant pour des Allemands il y a
une solennité
je ne dis pas que le Bundes de sac n'est
pas solennelle mais il y a une sonalité
qui qui a toute la le prestige de
l'histoire de la France ce qu'on a un
petit peu gommé en Allemagne dans un
bouliste qui est un parlement de travail
un parlement de travail dont
l'architecture est bien différente du
Palais Bourbon il faut le souligner
également voilà les deux présidentes qui
vont prendre le temps de s'installer et
de partager le perchoir on attend de
voir justement comment les choses vont
se mettre en place elles vont l'une
l'autre
occuper le siège du perchoir évidemment
c'est il y a elbron Pivet qui est
l'autre ici au Palais Bourbon qui voilà
monte au perchoir pour ouvrir cette
séance historique puisque c'est la
première fois qu'une séance au Parlement
va être qu'aux présidé par la France et
par l'Allemagne très bonne séance à tous
merci beaucoup à mes invités d'avoir
partagé ce temps de d'analyse la parole
donc à Yaël Braun Pivet
madame la Présidente de stage
cher Berber
mesdames et messieurs les députés
mes chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs
il y a 60 ans jour pour jour Charles de
Gaulle et Conrad Adenauer signait au
Palais de l'Élysée le traité d'amitié
franco-allemand
traité qui s'élève 18 ans seulement
après la fin de la Guerre mondiale la
réconciliation de nos deux peuples
l'encre des signatures a posé au bas du
traité était à peine sèche que le
général de Gaulle se leva
et il déclara
il n'y a pas un homme dans le monde qui
ne mesure l'importance capitale de cet
acte
non pas seulement parce qu'il tourne la
page après une si longue et 6 sanglantes
histoire de lutte et de combat
mais aussi parce qu'il ouvre toute
grande les portes d'un avenir nouveau
pour l'Allemagne
pour la France pour l'Europe et par
conséquent pour le monde
le traité de l'Elysée a donc été à la
fois un acte de paix et de
réconciliation et un projet d'avenir
fondé sur notre communauté de destin au
cœur de l'Europe
depuis la relation franco-allemande a
été a été rythmée par le souvenir des
affrontements passés mais aussi par la
construction d'une union toujours plus
profonde entre nos deux pays
les anniversaires de ce traité
historique ont été autant d'occasions
d'élargir et d'approfondir les liens
entre nos deux états
entre nos deux peuples
pour les 25 ans du traité de l'Elysée
des structures essentielles de
concertation a été mise en place tels
que le Conseil franco-allemand de
défense et de sécurité qui se réunit
aujourd'hui le Conseil économique est
financier franco-allemand et le Conseil
franco-allemand de l'environnement
le 22 janvier 2003 le 40e anniversaire
du traité a donné naissance au Conseil
des ministres franco-allemand qui se
réunit à nouveau aujourd'hui
le 22 janvier 2019 le traité
d'Aix-la-Chapelle a donné une nouvelle
dimension à la coopération entre nos
deux gouvernements en instituant des
consultations à tous les niveaux dans de
très nombreux domaines la politique
étrangère la défense la sécurité
l'environnement l'économie et la
jeunesse
c'est aussi à la faveur des
anniversaires du traité que l'Assemblée
nationale et le bundestax se sont
affirmés comme des acteurs essentiels de
la coopération franco-allemande les
réunions de nos deux assemblées en
séance plénière au château de Versailles
le 22 janvier 2003 pour les 40 ans du
traité de l'Elysée puis 10 ans plus tard
à Berlin au Bundestag sont encore dans
toutes les mémoires
plus récemment le 22 janvier 2018
l'Assemblée nationale et le bundesta ont
adopté une résolution commune qui
débouchera l'année suivante sur la
signature de l'accord parlementaire
franco-allemand
aujourd'hui nous sommes de nouveau
réunis pour dresser le bilan de ce qui a
été accompli et prendre la mesure du
chemin qu'il nous reste à parcourir en
tant que parlementaire et nous revient
de faire entendre les intérêts les
préoccupations de nos concitoyens faire
dialoguer nos différences rechercher des
compromis proposer des solutions et
contrôler l'action de nos gouvernements
à cet égard je tiens à saluer le
dynamisme de l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande en quelques années
cette jeune assemblée s'est imposée
comme une instance de dialogue précieuse
dont la mission première et essentielle
et de veiller à l'application des
traités de l'Elysée et d'Aix-la-Chapelle
depuis mars 2019 la face est réunie 11
fois en séance plénière et adopté de
nombreuses résolutions sur des sujets
touchants au quotidien de nos
concitoyens la lutte contre la pandémie
de covid 19 l'innovation le pacte vert
européen
lors de sa dernière séance plénière que
j'ai eu l'honneur de co-présider le 7
novembre dernier à Berlin LAFA a décidé
de mettre en place trois groupes de
travail sur l'avenir de l'Europe sur la
souveraineté énergétique et sur les
transpositions des directives
européennes et d'autres ces groupes
viennent d'être constitués aujourd'hui
je m'en félicite sous l'impulsion déco
président du bureau de la Fame Brigitte
et Neil Schmitt d'autres projets sont
d'ores et déjà en préparation et je
tiens à les en remercier ici très
chaleureusement
et le bureau de
là je sais que le bureau de la face ou
votre impulsion se réunira dès demain
matin je vais aussi évoquer la récente
adoption d'un programme de travail par
les deux commissions de la défense de
telles initiatives doivent être
encouragés étendues pour que le dialogue
et la concertation deviennent une
réalité dans tous les domaines d'intérêt
commun
depuis la signature du traité de
l'Elysée rarement il aura été aussi
crucial que la France et l'Allemagne se
consultent et agissent de concert cela
vaut pour nos deux gouvernements et cela
vaut également pour nos deux assemblées
plus que jamais l'Allemagne et la France
doivent unir leurs forces pour bâtir une
union forte souveraine et résiliente
pour défendre nos valeurs et la
démocratie
cherber
je crois que nous pouvons être fiers
d'avoir poursuivi et même prolonger ce
chemin de l'amitié franco-allemande nous
avons souhaité mettre au point ensemble
une déclaration commune préparée de
façon concertée avec ma première
vice-présidente et les présidents des
commissions compétents un texte ample
qui nous met aucun champ d'intervention
de l'action publique et qui nous donne
une feuille de route ambitieuse avenir
de l'Europe souveraineté énergétique
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
Europe de la défense indépendance
économique coopération transfrontalière
Europe sociale jeunesse recherche
égalité des sexes oui nos assemblées ont
leurs mots à dire dans la gestion des
affaires européennes et sur l'avenir de
notre continent nos concitoyens
attendent de nous des propositions et
des actions à nous de nous montrer à la
hauteur de ces enjeux
je sais pouvoir compter sur chacun
d'entre vous dans cette voie et d'avance
je vous remercie pour votre contribution
[Applaudissements]
donc j'invite à présent madame berbel
base présidente du Bundes à monter à la
tribune
[Applaudissements]
présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale cher collègue
du pont de stack je voudrais vous
souhaiter la bienvenue à cette séance de
travail et je vous remercie de votre
présence
votre présence montre combien étroites
sont les relations entre nos deux
parlements et témoignent de fait que
vous vous engagez pour renforcement
ultérieur de nos relations une amitié
entre la France et l'Allemagne
nombreuses générations ne pouvaient pas
le concevoir
aujourd'hui cette amitié est si
profondément enracinée qu'elle semble
incontournable
en commun nos analyses se rendre
ensemble à nos rendez-vous et échanges
parfois pour une journée leurs
ambassades mais il n'existe pas
d'inimités héréditaire mais il n'existe
pas d'amitié héréditaire même la plus
profonde amitié doit être entretenue
doit être soignée c'est pour cela que je
suis très heureux que nous ayons
aujourd'hui la possibilité en ce jour
anniversaire de renforcer nos relations
de façon tout à fait concrète l'Europe a
besoin de tandem franco-allemand nous
sommes tous conscients du fait que nous
vivons une période de profond de rupture
nous sommes arrivés à un moment qui est
décisif pour l'avenir de notre continent
nous devons participer de façon active à
configurer ces transformations nous
avons besoin de réponse intelligentes en
Europe non Parlement joue à cette gare
un rôle important au moins de novembre
nous nous sommes rencontrés dans le
cadre de l'assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande nous avons créé trois
groupes de travail et avant cette
réunion 2 de ces groupes se sont
constitués pour la première fois un gros
peut se penche sur la souveraineté
énergétique de l'Europe l'autre l'avenir
de l'Europe et enfin troisième gros œil
pour la transcription envoyé des
directives européennes législations
nationales
présidente Brown a Pivet et moi-même
vous présentons aujourd'hui une
déclaration commune chérie à elle je
suis très renaissance pour cette
coopération extrêmement fructueuse
nos entretiens sont toujours très
ouverts et très généreux pour moi ces
relations témoignent de notre amitié
personnelle mais aussi de la qualité des
relations entre nos deux parlements
notre déclaration témoigne de fait que
en tant que parlementaire nous portons
ensemble le responsabilité réel dans des
domaines cruciaux cette déclaration est
ambitieuse elle comporte toute une série
de projets que nous voulons promouvoir
dans le domaine de la défense dans le
domaine de la souveraineté énergétique
dans la lutte contre le changement
climatique et en matière de politique
migratoire
se caractérise par ses valeurs l'Europe
signifie démocratie et justice ces
valeurs
renforcent ou sont la force de nos
sociétés et c'est pour cela que nous
devons aussi réaliser des progrès en ce
qui concerne l'égalité entre hommes et
femmes et nous voulons prendre plus
intense nos échanges à ce sujet ce matin
j'ai la présidente Braun pivée et
moi-même avons rendu hommage à Simone
Veil j'essaie de pionnière des droits
des femmes a été la première femme à la
tête du Parlement européen sa vie et son
activité politique sur la meilleure
preuve que l'égalité ne concerne pas
seulement les femmes mais et dans
l'intérêt de nos sociétés dans leur
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
je suis fermement convaincue que nous
avons besoin d'un partenariat
franco-allemand qui soit fort pour
pouvoir
concevoir l'avenir de l'Europe l'échange
de nos jeunes à jouer un rôle essentiel
pour la construction de l'amitié entre
nos deux pays la présidente braune Pivet
et moi-même allons procédé par la suite
un échange avec les jeunes avec les
lycéens grâce à ces programmes
d'échanges nous pouvons consolider la
connaissance la sympathie et la
confiance de telles échanges sont
souvent aussi le premier pas pour un
emploi dans le pays partenaire
un échange il était particulièrement
motivant pour apprendre la langue du
pays partenaire malheureusement
de moins en moins de jeunes Allemands
après ne le français et de moins en
moins de jeunes Français apprennent
l'allemand c'est pour moi un sujet de
préoccupation et c'est pour cela que
nous souhaitons renforcer davantage
l'enseignement de français en Allemagne
et de l'allemand en France
en effet la langue et la clé pour une
meilleure compréhension la compréhension
n'est possible que si elle est portée
par un engagement je voudrais vous
remercier pour votre engagement pour
l'amitié franco-allemande et j'attends
avec impatience la discussion qui va
suivre pour un bon avenir de nos
citoyennes et de nos citoyens dans une
Europe souveraine unie et démocratique
merci
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
donc l'ordre du jour appelle un débat
relatif au projet de déclaration commune
des présidentes de l'Assemblée nationale
et du Bundestag qui vous a été transmis
par voie électronique et distribuée à
l'entrée de l'hémicycle je rappelle que
les prises de parole se déroulent selon
les modalités suivantes chaque assemblée
dispose d'un temps de parole total de 50
minutes réparties à la proportionnelle
entre ces groupes les groupes pouvaient
fractionner leur temps d'intervention de
tour de parole seront organisés par
ordre de représentativité des croissants
la première à prendre la parole la
présidente la coprésidente du bureau
donc de l'AFPA madame brigitte Klinkert
pour le groupe renaissance pour une
durée de 6 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente cheriel
Bundes stacks présidenti chers
nous voilà réunis pour célébrer le 60e
anniversaire du Traité de l'Elysée et à
travers lui le 60e anniversaire de la
réconciliation franco-allemande le
traité de l'Elysée a marqué le
commencement d'une amitié et d'une
coopération tout à fait inédite
entendre les critiques d'aujourd'hui et
les récidaires il pourrait apparaître
pierre tout était simple et
qu'aujourd'hui tout irait mal dans le
couple franco-allemand
en amour comme en amitié il ne peut y
avoir de trajectoire rectiligne
ce sont également les épreuves à
affronter ensemble qui font la valeur et
le sel des choses
construire cette relation puissante qui
est la nôtre aujourd'hui n'a pas été
chose facile pour Charles de Gaulle et
Conrad Adenauer l'affaire vivre et
grandir a toujours été une ardente
obligation pour leur successeur jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
si vous me permettez une pointe d'humour
un proverbe dit qu'un ami est quelqu'un
qui vous connaît par cœur et qui vous
aime quand même
nous connaissons nos différences nous
connaissons nos qualités et faiblesses
mutuelles et c'est dans le respect de
celle-ci que nous avons toujours
toujours su construire notre coopération
au service de nos peuples et de l'Europe
nous avons toujours su faire de nos
différences une force cette force que
seule le respect et la complémentarité
rendent possible
face au défi du monde et du temps ce que
nous poursuivons c'est l'unité et non
l'uniformité
pandémie mondiale guerre en Ukraine
inflation crise énergétique crise
climatique
appréhension des défis démographiques et
migratoires
souveraineté économique et technologique
lutte contre la désinformation et
défense de nos démocraties les défis
auxquels nous faisons face sont
vertigineux certains pourraient être
tentés de croire que dans cette
situation inédite France et Allemagne
s'en sortiraient chacune mieux de leur
côté
de manière solitaire permettre
permettrait davantage de réactivité et
de souplesse
ma conviction la plus profonde et que
cette vision de notre coopération serait
une illusion et une erreur face à
l'Histoire le temps et la liberté que
nous pourrions avoir l'impression de
gagner aujourd'hui nous finirions par
les payer au centuple et bien plus vite
que nous ne le pensons
célébrer le traité de l'Elysée n'a de
sens que si cela est l'occasion d'impact
sans cesse renouvelé et d'une
coopération sans cesse stimulée le
traité de l'Elysée et le traité
d'Aix-la-Chapelle nous ont donné des
outils puissants que nous devons
pleinement maîtriser et utiliser pour
léguer aux générations futures une
amitié encore plus grande plus forte
plus agile et plus efficace
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande en est l'une des plus
brillantes illustrations
réunis aujourd'hui dans cette émission
le témoin de l'histoire et de tant de
déclaration de guerre par le passé nous
avons aujourd'hui la magnifique mission
de construire les conditions d'une paix
durable et d'un futur désirable pour nos
concitoyens pour notre pays pour notre
si cher Europe en tant que parlementaire
nationaux au service de nos concitoyens
nous avons à coeur de jouer notre rôle
efficacement et concrètement les idées
ne manquent pas ainsi par exemple nous
pourrions imaginer de voir travailler
des binômes parlementaires
franco-allemand
œuvrant ensemble à l'élaboration et à
l'adoption d'une législation commune sur
des sujets d'intérêt partagés
aux côtés des initiatives
gouvernementales et citoyennes notre
assemblée parlementaire unique au monde
à plus que jamais un rôle central et
stratégique à jouer dans l'analyse des
situations dans la construction des
consensus et dans l'adoption de mesure
adaptées pour ne pas subir les
événements mais au contraire agir pour
inverser leur cours en ami et en
partenaires ce rôle fondamental que nous
avons à jouer a été clairement
identifié ce matin à la Sorbonne député
d'Alsace les chevillé au cœur et au
corps la conviction européenne et la
relation franco-allemande elles ne sont
pas et ne seront jamais des options pour
notre avenir pour la paix la sécurité et
la prospérité
avec avec mon collègue co-président du
bureau Nils Schmitt avec les présidentes
de l'Assemblée nationale et du Bundestag
nous avons à cœur que notre assemblées
soient en lieu de foisonnement de débats
de propositions et de construction
collective au service de ce projet
précieux et ambitieux qui est celui de
la relation franco-allemande cette
relation franco-allemande est
inestimable nous n'en sommes pas
propriétaire nous en sommes dépositaire
notre devoir politique et moral est de
la transmettre renforcée à ceux qui nous
succéderont ce travail nous entendons le
conduire dans le respect de chacune et
chacun dans le respect de nos
différences afin d'en faire des forces
et des atouts les mots peuvent paraître
pompeux mais les circonstances
exceptionnelles que nous traversons font
que notre mission et notre
responsabilité sont historiques je suis
convaincu que nous saurons en être digne
est cuni nous pourrons nous montrer à la
hauteur Esley
je vous remercie et je donne de la merci
beaucoup
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Rolf münchenich
pour le SPD pour une durée de 7 minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous transmettre les salutations les
plus cordiales du groupe SPD au bunders
dont une partie est venue ici avec nous
à Paris
et je me réjouis j'insiste là-dessus je
me réjouis que ce soit
des
parlementaire qui préside destinée de
nos parlements respectifs c'est un très
bon signe c'est très encourageant
mesdames et messieurs
J'ai vu tous ces jeunes gens ce matin je
les retrouve ici
de notre groupe parlementaire
50 députés
regarde donc ça aussi c'est une bonne
chose est-ce que je souhaite suggérer
ici c'est qu'il y ait encore plus de
jeunes parlementaires qui procède à des
échanges
et je crois qu'on doit pas se contenter
juste de l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande mais de
la coopération parlementaire de façon
générale
qu'il ne faut répéter toujours nous
sommes élus nous avons un mandat de la
part des électeurs pour exercer un
pouvoir au Parlement
on oublie souvent
certaines choses et donc je pense que
c'était une bonne chose dans le contexte
de l'anniversaire du traité de l'Elysée
et puis également dans le cadre du
traité
de manière institutionnelle la parole
des parlementaires car il est évident
que les parlements jouent un rôle
essentiels dans la coopération entre nos
deux pays elle ne n'existe pas seulement
au niveau gouvernemental chers collègues
et mesdames et messieurs
[Applaudissements]
c'est agréable de se réunir à Paris de
se réunir à Berlin mais le pays sont
grands nos pays sont composés de régions
très diverses de tradition également
très diverses et donc mesdames les
présidentes nous pourrions envisager
dans le cadre de la Fare d'aller
également dans les régions et de trouver
peut-être un ancrage plus régional aussi
pour notre assemblée
[Musique]
le mérite et surtout les citoyens le
mérite parce que cela montrerait plus de
proximité et du citoyen il y a trois
aspects sur lesquels je souhaite
insister le chancelier allemand au lave
scholls
suite à la Grèce suite à l'agression de
la de l'Ukraine par la Russie a parlé
d'un changement d'air car en effet la
plus grande guerre est menée sur le
territoire européen depuis la Seconde
Guerre mondiale donc bien entendu qu'il
faut clairement nommer les responsables
de cette guerre mais nous devons en ce
contexte faire nos preuves et également
aider l'ukraines à exercer son droit à
se défendre sur la base de la Charte des
Nations Unies et là je crois que la
France l'Allemagne sont aux côtés de
l'Ukraine
oui c'est vrai nous sommes confrontés à
un véritable changement d'air mais il y
aura encore beaucoup de changements
d'air dans le domaine de la politique
internationale mais il y a également
tout ce qui touche au monde du travail
au monde économique
nous autres
la France d'autres pays européens
ont décidé de créer un nouveau monde sur
le plan du travail de l'industrie parce
que nous voulons protéger le climat et
là je crois que l'échange entre deux
pays si importants est essentiel
il y a l'expérience bien entendu mais il
faut également donner plus de sécurité
aux salariés en la matière certes la
responsabilité sociale mais qui
s'accompagne également de droit
sous ce gouvernement à Berlin les
questions sociales sont constamment au
cœur de notre action nous l'avons montré
l'an dernier nous voulons effectivement
aider les gens dans des crises
existentielles mais nous voulons
également ancrer plus profondément les
droits sociaux il ne s'agit pas ici
de droits sociaux essentiel pour ces
individus il s'agit de droit que ces
individus peuvent faire valoir
éventuellement en cas de violation et il
y a quelques temps mon groupe
commentaires à élaborer une stratégie
pour
garantir l'avenir de la stratégie
industrielle européenne et ça je crois
que c'est certainement une question qui
pourrait être abordée entre la France et
l'Allemagne car entre nos deux pays nous
en avons fait l'expérience douloureuse
d'une part mais de l'autre côté il y a
eu des succès aussi dans les changements
structurels dont certaines régions
néanmoins souffrent encore donc
peut-être
mutualiser nos expériences pour faire
avancer une stratégie industrielle à
l'échelle européenne
[Applaudissements]
et messieurs je tiens à vous dire la
chose suivante dans le cadre de la
diplomatie internationale les parlements
à Renaissance et à jouer la politique en
matière de sécurité ne peut exister sans
démocratie c'est la raison pour laquelle
il faut impliquer les parlements les
parlementaires doivent s'engager pour
garantir la paix alors entre la France
l'Allemagne la paix a été faite même si
ce fut douloureux d'y parvenir mais la
paix est possible grâce entre autres
aussi au parlementaire donc encore une
fois un grand merci de nous avoir donné
cette possibilité et je vous souhaite
beaucoup de bonnes choses merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup
la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Frédéric Mertz pour la Cedeo CSO pour
une durée de 9 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale
pour moi c'est une honneur
exceptionnelle d'avoir l'opportunité
d'être ici à cette place aussi
aujourd'hui et prendre la parole devant
vous merci pour cette opportunité
[Applaudissements]
après la signature du traité de l'Elysée
il y a aujourd'hui 60 ans et exactement
Charles de Gaulle et Conrad Adenauer
se sont embrassés et c'est une image qui
a marqué l'histoire du monde un geste
symbolique un geste qui représente ou
qui symbolise l'amitié entre deux hommes
d'État et qui représente aussi la
réconciliation entre deux peuples la
France nous a tendu la main
18 ans après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
déclenchée par l'Allemagne et après
les crimes atroces de l'Holocauste et ça
ce fut vraiment
une chance pour l'histoire de
l'Allemagne et une chance pour
l'histoire de l'Europe
que la France nous est tendue la main
et conrada de nouer nous rappelle qu'en
dehors de la politique européenne ce qui
compte ce sont surtout les décisions qui
ont été prises par des personnalités et
qui caractérisent aujourd'hui la
relation franco-allemande notre amitié
elle ne repose pas seulement sur la
politique mais elle repose sur l'amitié
entre nos peuples
il y a tant de rencontres qui se sont
faites aussi entre citoyens depuis la
signature du traité de l'Élysée et ça
c'est véritablement le fondement même de
cette amitié franco-allemande
[Applaudissements]
justement l'objectif de ce traité d'une
part mener des consultations
communes à tous les niveaux
institutionnels pour restaurer une
confiance sur le plan politique mais
également
encourager à coopérer dans d'autres
domaines comme l'éducation la science
l'échange des jeunes les jumelages entre
villes
je permets de vous rappeler que il y a
50 ans pour la première fois j'ai eu la
possibilité donc il y a 50 ans de venir
en France le pays dans en Auvergne lors
d'un échange scolaire ce qui a bien
entendu marquer l'image que je me suis
faite de votre pays et je vous et je
reste reconnaissant à ma famille
d'accueil de la façon telle m'a
accueilli à l'époque et je reste
reconnaissant de toutes les rencontres
personnelles et privées que j'ai pu
avoir avec des Français depuis 1953
la France et l'Allemagne ont écrit
l'histoire
urbaine en commun
par des temps heureux et moins heureux
l'Europe a été divisée a été réunifiée
l'Allemagne était divisée et l'Allemagne
a été réunifiée Berlin à notre capital
était divisé et elle a été réunifiée
avec le soutien de nos amis français
et quand nous pensons à cet embrassade
entre de Gaulle et adonawar à l'époque
on pense aussi à la poignée demain entre
François Mitterrand et Helmut Cole
au cimetière de Verdun
depuis le 24 février 2022
et bien
les armes se font entendre en Europe la
guerre d'agression de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine montre que la guerre est
devenue un moyen politique en Europe
chers collègues ce changement d'air la
France et l'Allemagne
l'Union européenne et l'Occident
démocratique doivent
l'accompagner ce changement d'air et
doivent lutter avec détermination contre
cette guerre
car seul une victoire de l'Ukraine
permettra la paix et la sécurité en
Europe
nos valeurs notre Ordre sécuritaire on
le défend aussi dans le tomba sur France
président français l'a dit il y a
quelques jours
quel que soit le temps que cela prenne
pour que l'Ukraine remporte une victoire
l'Ukraine bénéficiera de notre soutien
on a beaucoup parlé de la perte
d'influence de l'Europe de l'occitan on
a beaucoup parlé de l'avènement des
autocraties mais si les 11 derniers mois
nous ont enseigné une chose c'est bien
cela ce qui est essentiel c'est notre
cohésion en Occident en Europe et
surtout la cohésion entre la France et
l'Allemagne c'est ainsi que nous
pourrons avancer
et nous le savons lorsque nous agissons
en commun nous pouvons aller très loin
on l'a vu ces 11 derniers mois il y a un
pays qui se bat pour sa liberté mais qui
se boit aussi avec courage pour notre
liberté et oui nous devons dire que nous
voulons la liberté et nous voulons nous
voulons la peine la paix accompagnée de
liberté et non pas la paix dans
l'oppression
alors nous parlons de beaucoup de
grandes questions changements climatique
souveraineté numérique défense
migrations dans notre quotidien en tant
que parlementaire nous avons bien
entendu des avis divergents mais il y a
une chose que le traité de les disait
nous rappelle constamment c'est la
volonté commune de trouver des solutions
pour que la pour bien comprendre que la
paix la liberté et la sécurité ne sont
possibles en Europe que si l'Allemagne
et la France travaillent main dans la
main et c'est dans ce contexte aussi que
nous continuons de coopérer en matière
d'éducation avec la jeunesse en cas de
l'ophage dans le cadre des échanges
scolaires également des échanges de
scientifiques
l'embrassaade entre
et de Gaulle la poignée de main entre
François Mitterrand et elmodcall le
symbolise cela montre que chaque fois
que les Français et les Allemands
entreprennent quelque chose en commun
dans tous les domaines et bien il
contribue à forger notre avenir commun
il y a 10 ans lorsqu'on a fêté le 50e
anniversaire du traité de l'Élysée nous
parle mens se sont rendu compte qu'il y
avait de nombreux nouveaux défis à
relever et on le voit aujourd'hui c'est
plus vrai que jamais la France
l'Allemagne dans les mois dans les
années à venir doivent veiller à ce que
l'Ukraine puisse se défendre avec succès
contre la Russie ensemble nous devons
veiller à la sécurité énergétique
au bien-être de nos pays et de l'Union
européenne il y a 10 ans les défis
étaient déjà énormes mais aujourd'hui
chers collègues c'est des filles n'ont
cessé de prendre en importance mais
comme il y a 10 ans aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la France l'Allemagne
doivent s'atteler en commun à des
solutions qui seront la base pour que ce
traité de l'Elysée se voit insuffler un
nouvel élan pour la décennie à venir
l'Assemblée nationale chers collègues
nous vous remercions de votre
hospitalité ici ou par les Bourbon et
nous sommes ravis d'approfondir la
métier
franco-allemand merci à vous merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Roger judo pour une durée de 4 minutes
pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
mesdames les présidentes
madeezer
je suis donc un nez juste après la
guerre et je sais de par ma propre
expérience que l'amitié franco-allemande
ne va pas de soi
une projection un concept politique le
monde est par essence une construction
politique
elle vise à créer des liens si étroits
entre nos donations qu'un recours ou un
retour au conflit devient impossible
Hubert Védrine dans un dialogue avec le
président
franco-allemande daxa Thomas boobat
affirmait que l'on constatait je cite un
décrochage des peuples depuis Maastricht
et qui fait des trouver un nouveau
narratif pour retrouver l'adhésion de
nos peuples et l'idée d'une amitié
franco-allemande et à l'idée européenne
Thomas Booba considère dans une
interview toute récente que c'est sur le
plan culturel que se construit la paix
en Europe beaucoup plus que sur le plan
économique ou institutionnel or que
constatons-nous sur le plan culturel
l'enseignement de l'allemand en France
est passé de plus de 600000 élèves
apprenant l'allemand en 1994 à 147 000
aujourd'hui où sont donc mesdames les
présidentes les progrès considérables
dont vous nous parlez
le nombre d'étudiants allemands en
France a diminué de 18% entre 2015 et
2020 le nombre de professeurs
d'Allemands en France est passé de 1089
en 2006 à 5801 en 2021 au CAPES
d'allemand 72% des postes ne sont pas
pourvus je suis la guise de formation je
suis germaniste une langue n'est pas
uniquement avec vecteur de communication
c'est la manifestation d'une identité
culturelle c'est l'âme d'un peuple qui
s'exprime dans sa langue c'est sa vision
du monde son rapport au temps à l'espace
à la destinée humaine aux autres
civilisations que verbalisent les mots
les tournures idiomatiques les
structures des phrases si nous
n'apprenons plus l'allemand si nous ne
transmettons pas à nos élèves la langue
des Allemands nous ne les comprendrons
plus dans tous les sens du terme nous
nous éloignerons d'eux ils redeviendront
étrangers c'est aussi simple que cela
certes les jumelages ont te communes
existent et vivent mais ils ne concerne
plus guère qu'une partie vieillissante
de la population tout le monde le sait
et ce modèle populaire est en voie
d'épuisement
mais chacun sait que la chaîne
franco-allemande
occupe une niche étroite et ne peut
concurrencer les grands médias français
et allemands
ou en est la politique culturelle
franco-allemande il y en a-t-il une
d'ailleurs combien de films allemands
sur nos écrans combien de livres
traduits combien d'articles dans nos
revues nous parlons de l'Allemagne du
mode de vie des Allemands de la société
allemande
posé ces questions cette iron tout se
passe comme si l'amitié entre les
peuples le franco-allemand du bas si on
peut dire était le grand oubliés de
notre indéfectible amitié si hautement
célébrée aujourd'hui il est temps
pensons-nous que l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande se
saisisse sérieusement de ce problème
qu'elle retrouve le contact avec le sol
les célébrations les commémorations les
déclarations ont leur noblesse et leur
utilité elle ne serait tenir lieu de
politique
songeons simplement pour conclure à ce
que Bertol Precht avait fait écrire
au-dessus de son bureau
la réalité est concrète je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à présent à Madame Brita à
solman
boundis Nancy
on dirait de 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente
de cette façon je suis très heureuse de
pouvoir m'adresser à vous madame Braun
Pivet madame Basset donc cher je
Présidente chers amis merci beaucoup
pour cette invitation et pour votre
accueil ici à Paris je pense que je peux
m'exprimer au nom de toute la délégation
allemande
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
de nous donner la possibilité de
séjourner ici à Paris aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas
ressentir ce que je sens aujourd'hui que
lorsque je suis devenu député je n'avais
pas imaginé que j'aurai l'honneur de
pouvoir prendre la parole devant
l'Assemblée nationale et je dis cela au
nom de toute ma délégation du pénis 90
des grenouille donc je suis heureuse de
pouvoir être ici aujourd'hui et de
pouvoir discuter avec vous je suis
heureuse de constater que nos deux
parlements l'Assemblée nationale et le
bundestaque commémore ensemble cet
anniversaire
60ème anniversaire du Traité de l'Elysée
60 ans d'amitié franco-allemande et de
réconciliation franco-allemande pour nos
concitoyens qui
son nez dans ce contexte cela semble
aller de soi mais pour mes
grands-parents et pour mes arrières au
grands-parents qui ne sont plus en vie
c'est tout à fait autre chose qu'une
évidence nous apprenons la langue de
l'autre nous voyageons dans nos pays
respectifs nous y passons des vacances
nous sommes familiers la culture du pays
partenaires nous avons des jumelages des
échanges de jeunes un travail
parlementaire commun nous organisons des
sessions communes nous discutons des
défis que le monde d'aujourd'hui pose à
nous et des difficultés qui peuvent se
présenter dans les régions frontalières
et ceci est merveilleux car c'est cela
qui fait l'Europe nous sommes des amis
nous sommes des partenaires et beaucoup
de choses nous unissent les
frontières se limitent au panneau que
nous trouvons le long de ces frontières
et lorsque nous nous affrontons
ça il y a peut-être sur les méthodes
mais jamais sur les objectifs car nous
avons des idéaux qui ne sont communs
nous n'avons peut-être pas forcément
toujours le même avis mais nous
comprenons la vie et l'opinion de
l'autre
et nous en discutons
nous vivons
dans des démocraties il y a bien ancré
et je suis
reconnaissante et heureuse je de
constater que cette amitié entre nous va
de soi et cette amitié est portée par
les jeunes également 60 ans ce n'est pas
très long
pour une amitié aussi profonde
notamment
si nous nous rappelons que des décennies
voire des siècles d'hostilités ont
précédé cette amitié pensons à la Grande
Guerre la Première Guerre mondiale
pensons au crime il y a de la deuxième
guerre mondiale qui ont vraiment ébranlé
ce monde mais ce sont des hommes
politiques courageux engagés visionnaire
qui ont su dépasser tout cela
avec créer des tensions et des problèmes
si importants au cours des décennies
précédentes qu'il semblait peu
envisageable qu'on puisse les dépasser
or ce fut le cas et aujourd'hui cette
amitié nous lisse aujourd'hui il s'agit
de l'avenir de l'Europe
l'avenir en paix et notre moitié
franco-allemande à jouer un rôle 13
important et cet égard car nous sommes
responsables de la paix et de la liberté
en Europe nous avons déjà évoqué
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
et dans les parlements en France et en
Allemagne nous sommes conscients du fait
qu'il nous faut apporter à l'Ukraine une
aide financière
militaire
civil c'est notre objectif pour l'avenir
merci
merci beaucoup la parole est à monsieur
Adrien Clouet pour le groupe LFI pour 7
minutes
[Applaudissements]
mesdames les présidentes
Madame et Monsieur les coprésidents du
bureau de la FA cher collègue du
bonestack et de l'Assemblée nationale
cette émission La rarement été si serein
depuis le mois de juin dernier et je
m'en félicite que nous puissions avoir
une occasion assez pacifiée d'échanger
les uns avec les autres et je
souhaiterais prendre la parole ici non
pas seulement en tant que député de la
France insoumise mais également en tant
que produit des programmes
franco-allemand à titre personnel
puisque j'ai moi-même passé le bac
franco-allemand j'ai travaillé avec nos
amis allemands au Bundestag durant un
certain temps
conduit ma thèse entre des centres de
recherche français allemands et me
retrouve aujourd'hui député de la
circonscription où est installé Airbus
l'entreprise franco-allemande pour
terminer comme vice-président du groupe
d'amitié franco-allemande donc plusieurs
motifs de venir ici prendre la parole et
échanger avec vous ainsi si le rapport
entre nos deux nations a pu me former
depuis ma jeunesse qui n'est pas si
lointaine quoi de plus logique puisque
nous avons français et allemand imposer
chacune et chacun une empreinte majeure
sur l'histoire de l'autre pays
souvenons-nous que l'accès de nos deux
régimes à la République et le produit de
ces grands crimes que sont les guerres
franco-allemandes
souvenons-nous que dans cette histoire
de violence qui a marqué le siècle passé
ce sont les mouvements ouvriers français
et allemands qui sont parvenus à établir
ce qui est notre bien le plus précieux
aujourd'hui sur le continent européen à
savoir l'état social celui-ci
constitue la fusion entre la République
telle qu'elle est née au lendemain de la
Grande Révolution française et le droit
à l'assurance et à la subsistance
conquis par la social-démocratie
allemande
quel meilleur exemple quel meilleur
exemple de cela pour en citer un au
hasard dans le moment que les caisses de
retraite que les caisses de retraite qui
sont créées en France sur inspiration de
cette conquête de 1889 en Allemagne et
qui certes qui sert elle-même d'appui au
retraites ouvrière et paysannes adoptés
en 1912 c'est par l'échange et l'Union
incessant entre progressistes de part et
d'autre du Rhin que les grandes
conquêtes du siècle ont lieu comme celle
de la retraite à 60 ans du côté français
ces coopération pratique ces coopération
pratique entre militantes associations
réseau intellectuel mouvement ouvrier
ont débouché sur des traités comme celui
de l'Élysée dont nous discutons
aujourd'hui ce traité visé à
circonscrire la concurrence entre nos
deux nations favoriser des coopérations
culturelles diplomatiques éducatives et
s'émanciper de Washington qu'en est-il
de ces objectifs aujourd'hui
la paix d'abord
la situation à l'est du continent nous
rappelle que la paix n'est jamais un
état de nature mais qu'elle est toujours
une construction patiente et déterminée
de personnes qui se battent pour la
construire et pour la maintenir
la vie des êtres humains commence
toujours par un processus biologique
leur survie et strictement dépendante de
l'ordre social dans lequel il viennent
au monde ils sont jetés aujourd'hui on
peut grandir entre la France et
l'Allemagne sans crainte
on peut grandir entre la France et
l'Allemagne sans anticiper la sauvagerie
du meurtre de masse avec le pays voisin
on peut grandir entre la France et
l'Allemagne sans se dire que des
marchands d'armes vont accumuler des
profits sur la décimation ponctuelle
d'une génération d'un côté ou de l'autre
du rein
et c'est sans doute pour cela que nous
ressentons ensemble l'épouvante de la
guerre d'agression tel qu'elle est
revenue en Europe sur
marche orientale
la culture ensuite
en la matière le traité avait des
objectifs très ambitieux qui n'ont pas
tous été tenus on l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises de moins en moins d'enfants
apprennent la langue de l'autre pays en
France on est passé de près d'un quart
d'une génération scolaire maîtrisant
l'allemand ou l'apprenant l'allemand en
1995 à 15 % aujourd'hui un chiffre
identique à l'Allemagne ou cette
proportion connaît le même type de recul
plus de 1000 postes d'enseignants
d'allemand n'ont pas été pourvu en
France dans la dernière décennie
conduisant une division par deux de
l'effectif total dans les établissements
publics en Allemagne les élèves
abandonnent également la langue
française notamment lorsqu'il passe au
niveau supérieur pour maximiser leur
note à laby tour
bref nous avons là-dessus un terrain de
travail un terrain de coopération pour
être à la hauteur des objectifs qui
avaient été fixés par ce traité qui nous
engage aujourd'hui
enfin la diplomatie
il n'y a pas un jus au niveau fonce à se
dire les choses il y a aujourd'hui un
certain éloignement entre les
perspectives géopolitiques et les
orientations diplomatiques de nos
gouvernements ce n'est pas tant le
préambule ajouté par le bundeslag en 63
qui aurait creusé ce fossé mais c'est
bien l'offensive de la diplomatie
états-unienne qui est parvenue sur
beaucoup de dossiers à enfoncer un coin
entre nos deux nations
enfoncer un coin dans nos coopérations
enfoncer un coin dans les programmes
industriels enfoncer un coin dans la
manière dont nous pouvions ensemble
construire un avenir économique
et cette offensive nord-américaine se
substitue parfois à toute idée de
solidarité européenne nous sommes ici
pour lutter contre cela et rétablir le
principe même du traité à savoir
l'indépendance diplomatique conjointe et
coordonnée entre nos deux nations
je parle bien ici d'idées de coopération
car les nos coopérations binationales
n'ont pas toujours été les plus
heureuses pour les pays du sud de
l'Europe notamment durant la crise des
dettes privées européennes
ainsi nous n'avons pas de raison de nous
réjouir lorsque les résultats sont en
demi teinte car d'immense défis
mobilisent nos peuples aujourd'hui
d'abord 17% des Français et des
Allemands vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté un enfant sur cinq vient au
monde sous le seuil de pauvreté un
enfant sur 5 et jeté au monde en France
et en Allemagne dans des conditions qui
ne respectent pas sa dignité humaine
fondamentale
cette crise sociale s'exprime même dans
l'espérance de vie qui stagne voire
recule pour les plus pauvres en France
et en Allemagne on a quitté le siècle où
chaque génération ont duré ses
souffrances convaincue que celle et ceux
d'après vivraient mieux pour une un
siècle où chacune et chacun s'efforent
de faire les efforts maximum pour
assurer qu'au moins ses enfants puissent
vivre aussi bien qu'elle et que on
connaît aujourd'hui la plus grande
catastrophe de l'espèce humaine le
dérèglement climatique qui met en jeu ça
survie même surtout ces points il nous
sommes qu'une rupture radicale et qu'une
bifurcation radicale est à l'ordre du
jour pour assurer notre subsistance et
nos coopérations à venir le projet de
déclaration aujourd'hui n'est pas à la
hauteur de ce que nous attendons et
comme le disait Alfred de bline où
trouver de l'aide lorsque les livres
sont muets et les grands esprits ne
prennent plus la parole pour nous ça a
toujours été dans nos peuples le peuple
français le peuple allemand avec son ou
parfois contre leur dirigeants
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Christian Dieu
pour le FDP pour une durée de 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
nationale madame la Présidente
parlementaire de l'Assemblée nationale
pour moi que le participer à une
rencontre historique si importante de
vous rencontrer tous personnellement et
de m'adresser à vous aujourd'hui en 1963
il y a une véritable césure dans les
relations franco-allemande après la
guerre la méfiance Charles de Gaulle et
Conrad Adenauer ont avec le traité de
l'Elysée posée les jalons pour l'une des
alliances les plus réussi du présent et
à l'époque ça n'avait rien d'évident
notre collègue merde a parlé de
l'embrassade entre les deux grands
hommes d'État
et surtout suite à cette terrible guerre
meurtrière déclenchée par l'Allemagne 18
ans auparavant et dans ce contexte en
tant qu'amant nous restons extrêmement
reconnaissant à Charles de Gaulle et au
peuple français nous avoir tendu la main
et d'avoir signé ce traité
[Applaudissements]
s
libérale
sont plus importantes que jamais mais ce
sont surtout les personnes des deux
côtés du Rhin
ce sont les citoyens aussi qui ont fait
les premiers pas et pas les responsables
politiques ils en ont fait un projet
d'école les citoyens avec des programmes
d'échanges pour des étudiants pour des
élèves un projet abstrait est devenu une
amitié et notre collègue clinquat vient
de la dire en amitié en amour tout n'est
pas rectiligne mon expérience
personnelle ne fait que le confirmer
j'ai vu que l'amitié franco-allemande a
directement influencé ma vie pour
arriver à quelque chose de positif
mon école organise aujourd'hui encore de
programme d'échan solaire avec une école
française alors à l'époque moi je me
suis rendu compte
que
c'était pas toujours facile j'avais
essuyé les refus d'une jeune femme que
je convoitais mais cela m'a permis de
rencontrer celle qui est aujourd'hui mon
épouse donc il y a toujours un côté
positif et donc elle avait préféré mon
meilleur ami et finalement ce que j'ai
appris c'est que la concurrence entre
amis mène toujours à quelque chose de
bon l'Europe moderne vit de partenariat
comme l'amitié franco-allemand et la
base la réconciliation entre nos deux
pays reste un avertissement à jamais qui
doit nous montrer à quel point il est
important d'entretenir cette amitié
l'Europe la France l'Allemagne sans
confrontés conjointement à de grands
défis surtout
la concurrence sur le plan des systèmes
avec des autocrates et donc la
souveraineté européenne sur le plan
géopolitique sur le plan ça doit être
notre objectif commun il faut s'y
atteler il faut poser les bons jalons
les
citoyens en France en Allemagne en
Europe doivent avoir l'impression que
nous le bâtons pour l'appel la liberté
et pour la prospérité et n'oublions pas
en une chose la guerre en Europe
c'est une chose que nous n'envisions
plus et pourtant elle est redevenue une
réalité au départ on ne savait pas si
l'Europe le partenariat transatlantique
dans le cadre le temps pourrait résister
mais c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
donc ce qui est arrivé c'est exactement
ce que craignait tant le régime russe la
cohésion l'unité des démocraties
européennes des valeurs européennes et
je finirai ce qu'on dit Emmanuel Macron
et Olaf Scholl ce que nous faisons nous
le ferons en tant que ce sera nécessaire
et je suis fière que nous ayons
lors de ce 60e anniversaire montré qu'il
y a raison de croire qu'il y a des
raisons de croire à la paix en Europe et
à la paix en Ukraine je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Patrick Hetzel
pour le groupe les républicains
madame la Présidente
Mesdames les présidentes mes chers
collègues nous voilà réunis en ce 22
janvier 2023 pour célébrer le 60e
anniversaire de la signature du traité
de l'Elysée par le chancelet adenauware
et le président de Gaulle ce fut alors
un acte politique extrêmement fort
sceller la réconciliation entre nos deux
nations européennes qui au cours de
l'histoire se sont si souvent combattus
tous deux avaient très douloureusement
vécu la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
savait qu'il faudrait construire une
paix durable basée sur des idées aux
démocratiques afin d'empêcher tout
retour du totalitarisme en Europe il
convenait d'apprendre du passé afin de
ne plus reproduire dans le futur les
mêmes erreurs il nous revient
aujourd'hui de porter cet héritage et
surtout de le faire fructifier car le
rôle d'un anniversaire et de faire un
bilan du passé pour ensuite envisager le
présent et le futur et c'est là que
notre assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande peut jouer un rôle
essentiel car n'oublions pas qu'elle a
elle-même été portée sur ses fonds
bâtissements par les présidents chublay
et Ferrand un moment où la relation
franco-allemande justement était en
difficulté notre rôle est essentiel
aujourd'hui en effet il serait illusoire
de se laisser porter par des messages
incantatoires et décalés il faut
qu'entre amis on se dise les choses
depuis quelques mois les mésentent
s'accumulent les 60 dernières années
d'amitié franco-allemande n'ont certes
pas toujours été paisibles mais nous
sommes actuellement à un moment très
critique il nous revient de le surmonter
je vais évidemment développer dans
quelques instants des éléments de fonds
à ce sujet toutefois je voudrais poser
un principe de base qui devrait nous
rassembler gouverner et prévoir et s'est
anticipé or à force d'avoir les yeux
rivés sur le guidon si vous me permettez
cette métaphore cycliste nous avons
d'une part collectivement perdu le sens
de l'anticipation et d'autre par
l'humilité de construire et de prendre
des décisions sur le moyen long terme
pour lesquels nous ne récolterons pas
personnellement les fruits politiques en
tant qu' élu je ne reprocherai jamais un
collègue allemand de défendre
l'Allemagne ni d'ailleurs un collègue
français de pour moi la France toutefois
il faut que nous soyons capables d'être
visionnaire et de conserver le cap pour
garder à l'esprit nous intérêts sur le
long terme c'est là où à de Nowhere et
de Gaulle était véritablement
visionnaire ils avaient compris qu'il y
avait un impératif existentiel pour que
nos deux nations se réconcilient et
surtout trouve les voix et moyen de
construire une partie de destinée
commune au sein de notre continent
européen Berlin et Paris ont la
responsabilité de dialoguer en confiance
même et surtout lorsque certains de nos
intérêts divergent et il faut surtout
garder le cap des intérêts vitaux pour
nos deux nations c'est sans doute la
crise énergétique qui a ces derniers
mois le plus révélé les tensions entre
nos deux pays reposant parti sur le gaz
pas cher en provenance de Russie et le
développement des exportations vers la
Chine les fondamentaux de l'économie
allemande ont été ébranlés l'Allemagne
tout naturellement a voulu à la fois
diversifier et sécuriser ses
approvisionnements en énergie dans le
monde ce qui a évidemment jeté un froid
de ce côté du Rhin par ailleurs nous
avons parfaitement conscience que la
gestion de nos finances publiques a le
don d'agacer outre-rein ou l'opinion
publique pense que désormais et
décidément les Français étaient des
cigales et nous connaissons tous la
leçon de la femme la fourmi annulement
envie de s'occuper de la cigale car cela
reviendrait à récompenser le vice au
détriment de la vertu mais nous devons
collectivement dépasser ces différences
de perspectives pour recréer les
conditions d'un dialogue autour de nos
intérêts en d'autres termes il est
évident et normal que chaque pays est et
défendre ses intérêts nationaux mais
nous devons retrouver le chemin d'un
dialogue sincère sur ces questions ne
soyons pas naïfs sur beaucoup de sujets
qu'il concerne l'économie la défense la
politique énergétique le commerce
international ou encore la géopolitique
nos deux pays partent souvent de points
de vue opposés le groupe parlementaire
les républicains pensent que plus que
jamais nous devons agir à deux niveaux
en matière franco-allemande il s'agit
d'une part de travailler sur des sujets
très concrets qui concernent le
quotidien de nos concitoyens entre la
France et l'Allemagne la fiscalité les
transports les échanges universitaires
les partenariats entre chercheurs et
j'en oublie notamment dans les espaces
transfrontaliers comme celui du Rhin
supérieur et d'autres parts sur des
sujets stratégiques qui concernent le
moyen long terme comme justement
l'économie la politique énergétique ou
la défense par des projets industriels
véritablement commun disons-le
clairement actuellement côté français
nous nous impatientons au sujet d'une
réforme du marché européen de
l'électricité que nous jugeons désormais
vital et indispensable pour assurer
notre survie et nous avons l'impression
que l'Allemagne procrastine chers
collègues nous devons pouvoir avancer
sur une telle question et je ne voudrais
pas finir mon propos sans mentionner un
dernier dossier stratégique dont nous
devons collectivement nous emparer
quelle réponse collective pourrons-nous
apporter au plan américain de réduction
de l'inflation dont les subventions
massives menacent fortement la
compétitivité aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup et donc je vais céder la
présidence de la séance à Madame berbel
base présidente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
extraordinaire
de pouvoir
occuper cette place aujourd'hui et ça on
le doit l'amitié franco-allemande merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
du groupe AFD
français
c'est un grand honneur que je puisse
donner ce discours aujourd'hui ici au
coeur de la démocratie française merci
beaucoup de cette occasion
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
c'est une journée de célébration une
journée de commémoration
il faut se souvenir
de ce qu'on réussi à faire comme Charles
de Gaulle il y a 60 ans après que Robert
Schuman
[Musique]
cela nous a apporté la paix et la
réconciliation ce que le président et le
chancelier n'ont pas dit ce matin
c'était que c'était un acte certes de
courage exceptionnel mais aussi un acte
de véritable foi de foi chrétienne en la
fraternité la nécessité de pardonner de
se réconcilier
c'est cela qui a permis en fait ce
succès mesdames et messieurs
vous avez lié la question de la relation
franco-allemande à celle de l'avenir de
l'Europe dans la déclaration commune et
si nous nous posons cette question
et bien il faudrait quand même
quel a été
en fait le modèle pour les fondateurs
pour ceux qui ont mené à cette
réconciliation Robert Schuman mettait en
garde contre un super état il mettait en
garde contre larogance il mettait en
garde sur les jugements les uns sur les
autres et par rapport à cela il opposait
l'esprit européen qui serait un esprit
de liberté pour que le citoyen puisse
s'épanouir un amour pour son propre pays
un amour au sens d'un patriotisme
positif aussi pour un autre pays dans le
cadre de l'échange et de l'amitié et
donc ce traité de l'Élysée qui disent
depuis 60 ans par mais surtout en fait
des rencontres parce que ce qui est
important
seul que l'Europe ne va pas sauver le
monde et puis il y a l'expérience des
migrations massives aussi alors qu'on
voit que ce sont toujours les mêmes
groupes qui full au pied l'esprit
européen lors de la Coupe du monde lors
de la fameuse nuit de la Saint Sylvestre
en Allemagne et puis vous demandez
l'accès libre à la vente
ou chaque année on va créer une grande
ville de bébé qui n'auront pas eu le
droit à la vie oui et puis ensuite
vous vous demandez madame la Présidente
on parle d'assurance
souveraine vous demandez à ce que les
deux
Parlement s'impliquent dans les
conclusions de la conclusion sur
l'avenir de l'Europe la même conférence
ou la Commission européenne à briefer
des gens pour qu'il
défendent leur avis et nous allons son
ressortis 800 d'opinion 800 avis
différents et je crois que les millions
de Français également en plus de poids
que cela et je crois que nous Parlement
ne doivent pas l'oublier
Robert Schuman mesdames et messieurs
patriotisme c'est un appel au
patriotisme un appel à la tradition
chrétienne à la démocratie et la
démocratie pour lui c'était de dire que
l'État est au service de son peuple
[Musique]
avec son peuple que ce soit en France
que ce soit en Allemagne vous devez vous
demander si à l'échelle européenne les
choses se passent véritablement comme ça
mesdames et messieurs vive l'amitié
franco-allemande mesdames et messieurs
mais ça doit avant tout être une amitié
entre nos états entre nos peuples entre
nos citoyens un grand merci
[Applaudissements]
bien
même si je n'ai pas tout compris on va
essayer de trouver un temps un peu plus
apaisé
mesdames les présidentes
mes chers collègues nous vous
accueillons chers
historique pour fêter ensemble les 60
ans du traité de l'Élysée qui a porté
les bases d'une coopération profonde
entre deux pays autrefois et demi
aujourd'hui amis
mon parcours
pas mal
d'intervenants on parlait de leur
parcours mon parcours comme celui de
certaines de mes collègues de mon groupe
à l'instar de Sabine Tillet et Delphine
linman témoignent d'une certaine manière
de cette transformation profonde des
relations entre nos deux pays je suis
Nasser en Allemagne en 1954 par les
hasards d'une affectation de mon père
militaire
en 1963 le président de Gaulle et le
Chancel lié à denauer signé le traité de
l'Élysée sur l'amitié franco-allemande
force et de reconnaître que ce traité a
atteint ses objectifs sur le
rapprochement des peuples d'abord et
notamment des jeunes on en a beaucoup
parlé ce matin et je les vois ici dans
haut de cette hémicycle
jeune de 22 ans alors responsable des
jeunes giscards génération sociale et
libérale en Béarn je me suis rendu à
l'invitation de nos amis de la youngo
union avec plusieurs de mes camarades
donc à voyager dans le Berlin divisé
nous avions dormi dans les locaux de
l'ophage l'Office franco-allemand de la
jeunesse et je pu me rendre compte à
l'époque des contrastes du Berlin
d'alors une ambiance particulière de
guerre froide mais en même temps une
vitalité incroyable
je n'ai pas fait de rencontre amoureuse
mais j'aurais peut-être pu et ce voyage
et ce voyage
et ce voyage a beaucoup fait pour la
compréhension de l'Allemagne pour un
béarné d'adoption comme moi cette
coopération s'est amine tienne et pas
seulement culturelle elle infuse dans
l'ensemble des pans de la société je
suis élu d'un Sud-Ouest où le nom
d'Airbus est synonyme pour de nombreuses
PME et de TI de contrats et d'emplois et
mais aussi
mais surtout d'innovation et de fierté
nos deux économies sont toujours plus
intégrées et cela ne peut être qu'une
bonne nouvelle elle est aussi
signe de politique la relation
franco-allemande et depuis 60 ans moteur
dans la construction européenne qui font
l'engagement politique que nombre de mes
collègues démocrates je veux prendre
pour exemple plan de relance européen
qui explique que notre continent se
remet mieux la crise de la covid que ce
que nous craignons au printemps 2020
nous avions su ensemble apprendre de nos
erreurs de 2008 et impulsé à de
nouvelles à deux une nouvelle dynamique
européenne la création de l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande en 2019
est aussi une nouvelle avancée si
auparavant les discussions étaient le
fait des pouvoirs exécutifs de part et
d'autre du Rhin nous nous réunissons
ensemble régulièrement notamment pour
tenir ses gouvernements comptables de
notre de cette relation et de rester
ensemble de une perspective pour notre
travail en commun il y a comme dans les
couples où toutes les familles parfois
des désaccords ou des rendez-vous
manqués c'est bien normal mais je crois
que la force de notre relation et que
nous savons que quelque soit ces
difficultés passagères nous nous
retrouverons toujours pour essayer
d'avancer ensemble le retour de la
guerre en Europe nous rappelle tant la
réussite historique représente cette
amitié que la nécessité de la préserver
et de la profondeur même au prix
d'efforts de chaque côté les démocrates
y prendront leur part je vous remercie
et vive l'amitié franco-allemande
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
délégué de l'Assemblée nationale chers
collègues
les orateurs précédents ont mis l'accent
sur le fait que la réconciliation
franco-allemande est une conquête unique
en son genre je suis heureux que nous
puissions commémorer aujourd'hui j'ai
l'anniversaire du traité de l'Élysée et
c'est une grande fierté pour moi de
pouvoir prendre la parole devant ou elle
s'est assemblée
je serai le seul orateur qui vient de
l'ex Allemagne de l'Est
et je dois dire que nous qui avons vécu
dans cette partie de l'Allemagne ceci
n'allait pas de soi c'était très loin de
nous nous l'avons entendu dans les
nouvelles
et avec l'unification allemande nous
avons voyagé conquis aussi que cette
amitié nous avons il y a aussi il y a eu
comme responsabilité il y a de
transmettre cela aux jeunes de cette
partie de l'Allemagne et nous avons fait
valoir que cette amitié ne va pas de soi
que c'est une véritable conquête
la réconciliation franco-allemande et
l'amitié franco-allemande est un pilier
de l'intégration européenne de cela a
été dit à plusieurs reprises et la
question a été posée à savoir quelle
Europe avec ses frontières au nord au
sud à l'ouest mais à l'est maintenant
nous avons un point
illégale de la Russie contre l'Ukraine
cette certainement pour nous
actuellement le plus grand défi la plus
grande crise en Europe les images que
nous voyons sont insupportables le
meurtre de la population civile la
destruction de village et de ville c'est
une folie il faut mettre un terme à
cette guerre et nous sommes tous
d'accord là-dessus le président Macron
c'est prononcé en faveur de négociation
et de paix avec la Russie et je pense
qu'il faudrait au moins
songer que il faudrait préconiser une
initiative de paix européenne
discuter uniquement de fournitures des
armes ne nous fera pas avancer nous
avons besoin d'une réponse européenne
concernant les relations futures avec la
Russie les temps ou Poutine
occupe le devant du pavé prendront afin
or il nous faudra concevoir les
relations avec la Russie qui suivront il
nous faut aussi discuter il y a de nos
approvisionnements en énergie de nos
approvisionnements en terre rare elle a
aussi il faut tenir compte de nos
différences le président le chancelier
ont parlé des aspects communs que nous
avons mais il existe en frontières de
grande différence c'est une et il y a
une question que je voudrais évoquer
savoir il y a la cohésion sociale cette
cohésion sociale et la condition
sinequanone pour notre capacité à agir
et je pense que se pose un certain
nombre de problèmes à ce sujet ce que
nous réalisons en Allemagne ne doit pas
obligatoirement être repris par la
France merci
[Applaudissements]
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
zergue
Président
c'est un grand bonheur de vous retrouver
ici à l'Assemblée nationale pour les 60
ans du traité l'Élysée cette Assemblée
nationale a accueilli Jean Jaurès et
Jean Jaurès en 1892 a publié une thèse
sur l'histoire du socialisme allemand
alors vous le voyez mes chers collègues
du Bundestag l'Assemblée nationale
l'Allemagne a toujours été très présente
dans le cœur des Français
réussir un anniversaire
c'est regarder l'avenir ensemble et
réussir cet avenir et cette ambition
commune aujourd'hui mes chers collègues
nous avons au moins quatre objectifs
devant nous la guerre en Ukraine la
guerre en Ukraine signifie la guerre en
Europe signifie la guerre contre la
démocratie et nous avons un devoir
absolu de porter une parole et une
action commune le deuxième objectif
le deuxième objectif porte sur les
droits démocratiques nous voyons qu'ils
sont bafoués en Iran en Afghanistan et
dans de nombreux pays nous avons un
devoir absolu de porter une parole
commune une parole franco-allemande une
parole qui soit forte qui pèse en Europe
pour que les droits démocratiques
puissent avoir un relais et des
ambassadeurs cet objectif est très
important nous avons un troisième
objectif qui est celui de la
souveraineté énergétique industrielle de
notre de notre continent la France et
l'Allemagne sont les deux plus grandes
économies du continent européen elles
ont par conséquent une responsabilité
très particulière pour que le continent
européen soit souverain sur sa
créativité sur son intelligence sur son
innovation là aussi nous devons nous ne
pouvons pas juste être les héritiers de
la génération Airbus nous devons être
les constructeurs d'un train européen
qui permette à nos continents de
véritablement faire la transition
écologique d'une énergie qui fasse que
notre continent européen redevienne ou
soit indépendant alors même que notre
dépendance vis-à-vis du reste du monde
est passé de 50% après de 60% en
l'espace de 15 ans nous avons un rôle
social
la lune l'amitié ne se construit jamais
sans les peuples et ce rôle social nous
devons en être les acteurs de au
quotidien c'est pour cela qu'il nous
faut réaffirmer le salaire minimum il
nous faut défendre être les
portes-paroles de toutes celles et tous
ceux qui n'en bénéficient pas
aujourd'hui alors mes chers collègues
pour y parvenir il faut que nous ayons
envie de partager une langue l'allemand
il faut que nous ayons plus d'heures de
cours d'allemand pour la jeunesse qui va
s'exprimer ici à l'Assemblée nationale
il faut aussi que nous ayons envie de
regarder la télévision avec Arte vous
savez vilibrante vilrante que j'admire
beaucoup disait niche
ça signifie que chaque époque doit
apporter ses propres réponses c'est à
nous de le faire mes chers collègues
merci beaucoup
nextérieur Frédéric valait tout en
raison Frédéric Valtou horizon
[Applaudissements]
mesdames les présidentes mes chers
collègues
c'est un immense honneur comme pour tous
les orateurs de célébrer aujourd'hui
notre relation d'amitié 60 ans après le
traité de l'Élysée
c'est un immense honneur et beaucoup
d'émotions pour moi-même puisque je suis
papa de deux enfants franco-allemand
évidemment donc les 7 cérémonie résonne
différemment peut-être pour moi cette
relation entre nos deux pays entre la
France et l'Allemagne nous avons vu nous
avons su la faire prospérer et ce malgré
nos différences il nous a fallu accepter
au fil du temps de composer l'un avec
l'autre de passer outre les cicatrices
de la guerre et de l'histoire de faire
coopérer deux puissances de culture de
vision du monde qui n'étaient pas
toujours au diapason certes nous avons
eu des désaccords mais nous avons
toujours su nous retrouver autant au
niveau des coopérations d'État et
politique qu'au niveau d'ailleurs de nos
villes et villages et n'oublions jamais
la force des prêts de 2500 jumelages qui
ont tissé des liens invisibles à l'oeil
mais solide entre nos deux pays et dans
cette période tourmentée nous retrouvait
encore et toujours est une ardente
obligation d'abord parce que la guerre
revient en Europe face à l'agression de
l'Ukraine par la Russie de Vladimir
Poutine nous devons nous montrer Unis
solidaire
et solidaire du peuple ukrainien nous
devons continuer à coordonner notre
réponse et fournir à ce peuple ami les
moyens d'assurer sa défense si l'Ukraine
tombe c'est l'Europe qui sera menacé
ensuite
parce que la guerre et la pandémie nous
ont montré que nous devons rendre nos
démocraties plus résilientes nous ne
pouvons pas dépendre des uns pour notre
énergie et nos ressources et des autres
pour assurer notre sécurité le couple
franco-allemand a un rôle majeur à jouer
pour construire une véritable autonomie
stratégique au niveau européen car c'est
souvent bien l'Europe qui nous permet de
nous retrouver l'Europe qui nous pousse
à chaque fois à trouver des compromis
sans le couple franco-allemand de De
Gaulle Adenauer pendant la guerre froide
de Mitterrand à Helmut call pendant la
chute du mur de Berlin et sans l'action
conjoint de nos présidents de la
République et de la chancelière
allemande soit pendant la crise
financière soit pendant la pandémie
cette Europe n'aurait pas pu exister ou
n'existerait peut-être plus du tout et
aujourd'hui chers collègues chers
collègues du bun nous sommes côte à côte
dans ce haut lieu de la démocratie
française n'en faisons pas qu'un symbole
les déclarations du président de la
République et du chancelier ce matin
pose les fondements d'une amitié
renouvelée engageons-nous dans cette
voie là face aux défis de notre temps le
groupe horizon et apparenté que j'ai
l'honneur de représenter aujourd'hui
souhaite avec vous tous
œuvré à cette amitié renouvelée et
construire l'Europe de demain
direchafendaz vive la Mickey l'amitié
franco-allemande
[Applaudissements]
Cyrielle châtelain les écologistes
mesdames les présidents de l'Assemblée
nationale et du bundo stack chers
collègues
librecoeghinen une collègue
belle jeunesse de nos deux pays
younger under Biden c'est à vous que je
m'adresse à vous qui pour certains
pourrait manquer d'enthousiasme à
célébrer ce 60e anniversaire car
qu'est-ce qu'un anniversaire de 60
années quand on n'a pas encore 20 ans
Barbara immense artiste parler du désir
de réconciliation comme du plus grand
rempart contre l'oubli et comme elle
avait raison de faire de ce désir de
parler de ce désir pour écarter l'oubli
mais dans les années 60 la jeunesse
n'était pas privée de son insouciance et
le désir prenait la forme d'une nouvelle
page à écrire quelle page offrons-nous
nous nous adultes nous parlementaires à
cette nouvelle génération à cette
génération qui s'est autoproclamé dit
lait de ce canards
il est là notre défi commun leur
permettent d'écrire cette nouvelle page
pour cela nous devons entendre nous
devons écouter et nous devons laisser
décider cette génération c'est bien là
l'esprit du traité de l'Élysée car la
jeunesse elle ne tergiverse pas pour
près de 65 % des jeunes Allemands et
Français déclarent que le plus grand
défi de notre époque est le dérèglement
climatique écoutons-les les petits pas
ne suffiront pas que cette amitié
franco-allemande au cœur de l'Europe
retrouve un souffle dans une ambition
écologique que le monde pourrait bien
nous envier
enfin prenons garde
n'oublions rien du traité d'amitié qui
nous réunit nous devons tenir le rempart
contre la haine de l'autre qui a plongé
non seulement nos deux pays mais le
monde dans le chaos est l'indicible pour
répondre au débat nauséabond qui
traverse notre robe j'emprunte encore
ces mots à Barbara intemporels tenter
les justes et tant pis pour ceux qui
s'étonnent et que les autres me
pardonnent mais les enfants ce sont les
mêmes à Paris ou à guttingen et
j'ajouterai ce sont les mêmes à Kiev à
Kaboul Adamas à Téhéran ou à bedoa ne
leur tournons pas le dos
de la Gauche démocrate et républicaine
mesdames
mes chers collègues du bundenstad et de
l'Assemblée nationale quel joie
d'accueillir au sein de notre hémicycle
nos amis allemands pour cet hommage
émouvant à l'amitié entre nos deux
peuples à l'occasion de ce 60e
anniversaire du Traité de l'Elysée ce
traité qui a scellé la réconciliation de
nos deux pays dont les pages sombres de
l'histoire commune n'étaient pas une
fatalité a permis ce que Paul Eluard
écrivait de vérifier la douce loi des
hommes celle de changer les ennemis en
frères
ici même sur ces bancs le grand Victor
Hugo dans un discours visionnaire
prononcé le premier mars 1871 liée déjà
le destin de l'Europe à la fraternité
entre la France et sa soeur l'Allemagne
depuis 60 ans c'est cette fraternité en
acte que nous tentons de faire vivre que
des dizaines de villes dans le cadre de
jumelage culturel sportif linguistique
éducatif font vivre y compris ce
week-end comme à Vierzon dont je suis
l'élu qui accueille ses amis de bitter
Feld Wolfun de sax anald et de rainburg
du chef-l'isolstein bienvenue à eux dans
ma bonne ville en ces temps dramatique
où l'agression de l'Ukraine par la
Russie porte le feu des canons au cœur
de notre continent l'histoire récente de
notre de nos relations de l'amitié qui
s'est nouée de la culture partagée est
un exemple concret que la paix entre les
peuples ne se décrète pas elle se
construit
aussi notre force commune et bien
entendu de soutenir le peuple ukrainien
mais attention à ne pas verser dans une
surenchère belliciste qui devient
incontrôlable
dans le même temps nous savons tous que
la paix la fraternité sont les victimes
des retours des nationalistes mais aussi
de la vie chère de la crise sociale et
pour y échapper l'esprit de
responsabilité c'est de combattre les
inégalités grandissantes c'est de
réorienter une Europe des marchés et des
marchands vers une Europe sociale c'est
d'accueillir celles et ceux qui fuient
les guerres les famines à la catastrophe
climatique il n'existera pas de paix
durable sans une nouvelle répartition
des richesses sur notre globe que ce
soit centième anniversaire du Traité de
l'Elysée marque le point de départ d'une
Europe respectueuse des peuples de leur
souveraineté une Europe ouverte et
solidaire une Europe de paix est-ce
l'ébeu des frangins
folker merci
[Applaudissements]
et territoire
mesdames les présidentes Frauen
présidenton chers collègues des deux
côtés du Rhin 60 ans jour pour jour
après la signature du traité de l'Élysée
nous nous retrouvons réunis député
allemand et français à l'Assemblée
nationale pour commémorer ce jour qui
celles d'amitié indéfectible entre nos
deux peuples
séparés par les guerres au cours du 19e
et 20e siècle cette amitié à l'origine
de la construction européenne est
aujourd'hui mise à l'épreuve par le
retour de la guerre de haute intensité
en Europe une amitié se forgeant dans
les moments difficiles cette époque
troublée est l'occasion de démontrer la
robustesse de nos liens face au
déstabilisation de toutes parts le
couple franco-allemand a le devoir
d'assumer pleinement son rôle historique
de moteur pour impulser une nouvelle
dynamique de projets européens après une
succession de crise le brexit le covid
la guerre en Ukraine
c'est le député de la circonscription de
la commune de La Flamengrie dans l'Aisne
où se situe le monument de la pierre de
droit la même où a été sonnée le 1er
cessez le feu de la guerre 14-18 qui
vous le dit la guerre nous a séparés
elle doit aujourd'hui nous permettre de
nous souder davantage mais comme l'avait
déjà compris Charles de Gaulle et Conrad
Adenauer il faut aller bien plus loin
que les questions de défense pour
renforcer nos liens tels que dans
l'éducation l'apprentissage de la langue
du voisin les échanges commerciaux
scientifiques ou culturelles
extension du traité de l'Elysée le
traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle signé 56 ans
plus tard propose d'aller plus loin en
traduisant ce lien d'amitié par de
nouveaux projets communs concrets
notamment en termes de coopération
transportalière d'environnement et
d'efficacité énergétique nous soutenons
vigoureusement cette ambition
car en définitive ce sont bien les
projets congrès qui renforcent l'amitié
de nos deux peuples et nous permettront
et permettront à nos concitoyens à
l'heure où le repli populiste et la
guerre menace de guerre des fois dans
l'idéal européen de démocratie et de
solidarité c'est aussi toute
l'importance de la commémoration
d'aujourd'hui qui permet d'envoyer un
message à nos partenaires de l'Union
européenne mais aussi aux forces
déstabilisées des stabilisatrices de
l'Europe unie nous sommes une ini nous
resterons ferraille zinfir feraite
blybenvir vive l'amitié franco-allemande
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la présidente
président
ou une collèguemines
a une grossesse
les 60 ans du traité de l'Élysée que
nous commémorons aujourd'hui représente
disons le d'emblée un message d'espoir
en cette époque un certain car cet
anniversaire est la preuve qu'une amitié
durable et sans cesse renouvelée est
possible entre les peuples même entre
ceux qui comme les peuples français et
allemand ont imprimé dans leur mémoire
le poids de l'histoire et de ses
tragédies
pour des décors à une amitié que
beaucoup à l'époque croyait impossible
entre nos deux nations Charles de Gaulle
et coderrada denauer ont eu l'idée
visionnaires d'instaurer par ce traité
des échanges réguliers systématiques
entre nos deux états
car ils étaient conscients que seuls des
échanges poussés entre nos deux peuples
pourrait permettre de créer ce le lien
de confiance sans lequel aucune amitié
n'est possible
un lien de confiance et une amitié qui
soyons clairs ne font pas fille de nos
différences mais nous permettent de nous
enrichir au travers d'elle
je le sais d'autant mieux que moi-même
comme beaucoup d'orateurs j'ai plus
jeune pu vivre en Allemagne une année
d'études à Munich puis deux années de
travail à Stuttgart ces années de
formation ont une grande importance dans
ma construction personnelle et dans mon
attachement à l'Allemagne
c'est cet esprit des chances de
découverte de l'autre que le traité de
l'Élysée a d'emblé choisi comme Simon de
l'amitié franco-allemande et qui se
retrouve désormais dans les valeurs
fondamentales de la construction
européenne
dans cette perspective le traité
d’excès-la-chapelle signé en 2019
constitue également une nouvelle avancée
qu'il convient de saluer avec la
priorité qu'il a donné à l'élargissement
des programmes de mobilité pour les
jeunes ou encore la mise en place d'un
fond citoyen commun pour appuyer des
projets communs
c'est également cet esprit d'échange et
d'apprentissage réciproque que je
souhaite mettre au coeur des travaux du
groupe d'amitié France Allemagne de
l'Assemblée nationale que j'ai l'honneur
de présider et je veux d'ailleurs saluer
mon homologue Nicole weissig
car aujourd'hui autant qu'à l'époque du
traité de l'Elysée la coopération
franco-allemande apparaît indispensable
afin de faire face aux défis que
traverse l'Europe nous l'avons vu avec
la pandémie de covid-19 et ses
conséquences face auxquelles nous avons
pu ensemble manifester une réponse forte
nous le voyons désormais avec la guerre
en Ukraine et son impact mondial devant
lequel nous nous devons de parler d'une
seule voix en défense des valeurs
démocratiques auxquelles nos deux états
sont six à attacher
dépositaire d'un héritage partagé et
tributaire d'un destin commun la France
et l'Allemagne doivent avoir à coeur de
cultiver encore et toujours ce lien qui
nous unit il est l'une des clés pour
affronter les défis de notre temps et
préserver ainsi les valeurs qui sont les
nôtres
c'est pourquoi je ne peux être fier
aujourd'hui de contribuer avec vous
aujourd'hui à cet espoir que représente
notre amitié l'amitié franco-allemande
je vous remercie Philippe
[Applaudissements]
madame la présente la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale mes chers
collègues
nous fêtons aujourd'hui le 60e
anniversaire du Traité de l'Elysée signé
à l'initiativiste historique du
chancelier conradon hower et du général
de Gaulle
deux pays qui se voyaient comme des
ennemis héréditaires après trois guerres
en moins d'un siècle faisait le choix de
la réconciliation ce bilatéralisme
unique au monde et le fruit d'une audace
qui nous faut retrouver pour faire face
en européen aux enjeux de notre temps
être fidèle à l'ambition du traité de
l'Elysée demande 60 ans plus tard alors
que la guerre fait rage en Europe au
cœur de celle-ci et non pas aux portes
de d'autres continents comme nous
l'entendons trop souvent de privilégier
l'action sans tabou sans crainte pour
bâtir une souveraineté européenne
inédite le 22 janvier 1963 le tandem
franco-allemand devenait le moteur
décisif de la construction européenne
sans lui il n'y aurait eu ni le marché
unique ni l'euro ni l'enfant en commun
ni le plan de relance post covid ni une
réponse européenne à l'agression russe
contre l'Ukraine aussi rapide et unie le
22 janvier 2023 le tandem
franco-allemand doit devenir le
continent le moteur d'un continent
pleinement souvent qui décide par
lui-même et pour lui-même
sur les deux rives du Rhin chacun a
compris que les conditions du succès
tentent individuel que collectif repose
sur une dynamique un binôme
franco-allemand allié à une ambition
européenne aujourd'hui notre rôle de
partenaire exigeant et d'ouvrir un
nouveau cycle dans notre relation pour
faire advenir la souveraineté européenne
dans un monde redevenu instable
comme l'avait pressenti le président de
la République lors de son discours de la
Sorbonne en 2017 et comme la reconnue le
Cancelier fiols lors de son discours de
Prague en 2022 il est temps de bâtir
nous-même français et allemand la
véritable indépendance du continent
qu'on se venons-nous voyons-nous
vivons-nous comme ce que nous sommes une
Europe puissance à l'heure du réveil des
empires au moment où le tragique est de
retour en Europe ou l'Ukraine est
attaqué ou des citoyens européens sont
les victimes des bombes des chars des
tirs de la torture russe il est de notre
responsabilité commune de nous dresser
contre la sauvagerie de Vladimir Poutine
de semillis et de continuer à faire
front commun et de dire clairement
clairement que l'impérialisme de
Vladimir Poutine ne vaincra pas que nous
ne laisserons pas l'Europe retomber dans
la violence le nationalisme et la haine
au contraire nous devons accompagner le
chemin européen de l'Ukraine mais plus
encore nous devons renforcer l'unité de
la communauté politique européenne qui
vient de naître à Prague il y a quelques
semaines de cela
de manière coordonnée nous avons livré
des armes et des munitions à l'héroïque
armée ukrainienne et nous devons
continuer à fournir toute l'aide à
l'Ukraine dont elle a besoin toute
l'aide dont elle a besoin alors que nous
approchons du premier anniversaire de la
guerre certains de nos partenaires
européens ils sont déjà prêts nous
manquons pas ce rendez-vous mais au-delà
de ce conflit dont chacun souhaite qu'il
se termine vite par la victoire de
l'Ukraine il flotte dans l'air comme
matsitten 22 avec la nécessité d'agir en
européen
saisissons-nous de cette crise pour
faire avancer la défense européenne afin
de ne plus dépendre quasi exclusivement
d'autres pour assurer notre sécurité
collective agir en européen nécessite
aussi de ne plus penser seulement en
France en franco-français ou en Germano
allemand en matière d'énergie la guerre
en Ukraine et le dérèglement climatique
font chaque jour plus sentir la
nécessité de disposer de sources
d'approvisionnement sur et des carbonées
si nos deux pays ont fait des choix en
matière de 1000 énergétique notre
responsabilité est d'accélérer nos
efforts d'innovation et de mettre en
commun les savoir-faire nationaux
d'excellence il en va de même pour
l'industrie et les technologies d'avenir
le protectionnisme économique et
redevenu une réalité comme le monde
l'inflation
américain il est temps d'agir pour que
nos fleurons technologiques d'avenir
restent en Europe pour cela il nous faut
bâtir une réponse européenne souveraine
pour investir dans l'avenir et les
secteurs stratégiques pourquoi ne pas
envisager un nouvel emprunt commun
pourquoi ne pas créer un fonds européen
de souveraineté à partir des fonds
européens non utilisés il est temps
d'agir pour que nos technologies
d'avenir ne partent pas de l'autre côté
de l'Atlantique mes chers collègues
bâtir une souveraineté européenne voilà
l'ambition de la relation entre la
France et l'Allemagne pour les années à
venir d'aucun nous disent déjà que c'est
impossible mais il ne connaissent pas la
force de l'Alliance franco-allemande
ce qui nous ont précédés nous ont montré
qu'ils étaient capables de tourner la
page de décennies de rivalité et de
guerre mortifères
cela nous oblige mais plus encore c'est
pour notre jeunesse pour nos enfants
pour la prochaine génération pour qu'ils
puissent eux aussi vivre sur un
continent de paix de liberté de
prospérité que nous devons défendre
l'Europe vive l'Allemagne vive la France
vive l'amitié franco-allemande et vive
l'Europe
[Applaudissements]
l'extrait
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale chers collègues
à remercier nos auteurs français de nous
accueillir dans ce magnifique cadre dans
lequel nous commémorons ensemble
aujourd'hui le 60e anniversaire du
traité de l'Élysée je dois dire qu'à
Berlin on a pas d'aussi belles sales les
salles aussi somptueuses
[Applaudissements]
il est bon de rappeler que la métier
franco-allemande est avant tout une
amitié entre nos peuples les traités
sont certains portants ils sont toujours
un symbole mais tout ça ne fonctionne
pas sans les liens personnels entre les
citoyens des deux côtés du Rhin car
c'est eux qui insulte une véritable vie
à cette amitié et à mon sens il existe
peu de pays aussi interdépendants que la
France et l'Allemagne cela a déjà été
dit à de nombreuses reprises aujourd'hui
il y a là une institution clé c'est
l'ophage l'office franco-allemande pour
la jeunesse on a entendu monsieur dur de
qu'il aurait quasiment et poser une
Française ça n'est pas le cas pour
Monsieur Mathieu mais par exemple
l'ophage qui a été créé il y a 60 ans a
permis à 9 millions et demi de jeunes
gens de faire l'expérience du pays
voisin de lier des amitiés qui durent
souvent toute la vie et ce qui est
particulièrement beau c'est que ce
modèle très réussi nous pouvons en fait
l'appliquer ailleurs parce que il y a
quelques années il y a un bureau
ou un office pour la jeunesse pour les 6
pays des Balkans qui a été mis en place
pour que ces jeunes chants apprennent à
se connaître après n'a surmonter les
conflits du passé et je crois que c'est
un extraordinaire exemple de la façon
dont la France l’allemagne peuvent
veiller à ce que l'Europe entière avance
dans son processus d'unification autre
point d'ancrage important pour les liens
entre nos pays ce sont plus de 2200
jumelage entre ville et région qui
permettent un échange à gestion
régionale et locale et puis il y a
beaucoup d'initiatives d'associations
qui ont une activité trans régionale
dans le domaine de l'éducation par
exemple mais malgré l'engagement un
défectible qui existe dans nos pays on
manque souvent de ressources financières
pour ces projets ce sont des gens qui
ont des idées qui veulent les mettre en
pratique c'est la raison pour laquelle
il est si important
le traité de la chapelle nous ayons mis
en place le fond citoyen franco-allemand
qui appuie cet engagement nous y aurons
encore beaucoup recours nous en aurons
besoin dans les années à venir et lors
d'une journée de commémoration comme
aujourd'hui on regarde à quoi nous
sommes parvenus il y a eu des rivalités
entre nos deux pays qui ont culminé dans
la première et la seconde guerre
mondiale et cela a toujours mené
l'Europe à la catastrophe alors il y a
eu des politiques comme Charles de
Gaulle Conrad Adenauer qui ont réussi à
surmonter l'inimité héréditaire entre
nos deux pays pour les mener à la
réconciliation cela a déjà été dit à de
nombreuses reprises mais pour moi cela
relève encore quasiment du miracle un
miracle appelé par ses deux hommes
lorsqu'ils sont signés ce traité de
l'Élysée et bien la fin de la guerre
remontait à moins de 20 ans vient de le
dire 18 ans 18 ans c'est quoi dans une
vie les toutes les familles avaient
encore la mémoire des atrocités de la
guerre et je suis certaine que les
traumatismes de la guerre était encore
omniprésent et dans ce contexte c'est de
peuple se sont tendus la main ils ont pu
s'acclé à forger un avenir commun nos
autres ici nous sommes des enfants de
cette paix nous avons une responsabilité
particulière pour nos enfants pour nos
petits-enfants pour qu'ils puissent
vivre dans la paix et dans l'amitié
[Applaudissements]
la raison pour laquelle le travail de
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemand des si important
alors certes des parlementaires des deux
pays élabore en commun des propositions
de solutions sur des problèmes
importants et communs mais au niveau des
parlements et donc au niveau de nos
peuples cela permet de renforcer la
compréhension mutuelle et de dépasser
les divergences et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il est bon qu'une déclaration
commune aient été prévue afin
d'approfondir la coopération
franco-allemande pour l'avenir de
l'Europe pour le changement climatique
sur la souveraineté énergétique et sur
la défense cette coopération est
essentielle on le voit dans le cadre de
la libre circulation et des migrations
car cela touche justement
de se mettre d'accord sur des principes
comme les migrations l'immigration
resteront à l'avenir des questions
essentielles pour l'Europe cette
question des migration
touche d'ailleurs beaucoup de
parlementaires dont moi tout
personnellement mon père a été au lycée
français à Istanbul et c'est là-bas
qu'il a fait son bac en français
ensuite il a émigré en Allemagne
pourquoi je ne sais pas mais c'est en
Allemagne qu'il a émigré et à la maison
il parlait toujours avec enthousiasme de
la langue française
et bien il avait bien entendu aussi a
pris l'allemand il trouvait que c'était
une langue claire directe pour le
travail pour les échanges commerciaux
mais il trouvait que la prononcée était
difficile la passion il la ressentait
plutôt en français et il est important
que nos enfants nos petits-enfants
apprennent respectivement le français et
l'allemand mais il faut l'avouer ces
langues sont difficiles ils ont besoin
de notre aide de notre soutien et il
faut aussi se battre pour y mettre un
petit peu de passion
[Applaudissements]
depuis quelques années au sein de notre
assemblée commune je contribue à
renforcer les relations franco-allemande
mais encore une fois ce qui est
important ce sont les individus les
citoyens vivent leur envie de l'amitié
francophone merci beaucoup
nextérieur
la parole et Madame Patricia lips CDI
CSU
[Applaudissements]
le président de l'Assemblée nationale
madame la Présidente de Bundes stock
chers amis chef je me suis longtemps
demandé si je devais le dire ou non mais
je suis né en 1963
et lors du 40e anniversaire du traité de
l'Élysée j'ai déjà été ici à Paris à
l'époque nous nous sommes réunis à
Versailles aujourd'hui je suis de
nouveau à Paris
et vous pourrez aisément concevoir que
ceci est une grande joie et surtout un
grand honneur de pouvoir à nouveau
participer à ces commémorations
le monde se présente au genre de vie
avec une nouvelle dynamique au vu des
changements
géopolitiques nous avons besoin d'une
Union européenne qui puisse s'affirmer
nous devons renforcer notre sécurité
notre souveraineté et notre
compétitivité ce qui est en jeu c'est
notre liberté c'est notre prospérité
et il a été dit déjà maintes fois que
cela dépendrait largement de nos deux
pays
sont des pays de l'Europe nous devons
contribuer à concevoir cette Europe de
l'avenir il faut nous engager avec
courage avec passion comme nos
prédécesseurs l'ont fait
car ce il y a des visionnaires je pense
à Charles de Gaulle je pense à Conrad
Adenauer qui ont en fait préparé le
chemin de l'amitié franco-allemande et
qui ont dépassé ce faisant
l'inimité héréditaire entre nos deux
pays
lors de la signature de ce traité de
l'Élysée
donc de se traiter de l'amitié
la Première Guerre mondiale remontait à
45 ans et la deuxième guerre mondiale à
18 ans a été guère qui ont divisé
pendant des décennies notre continent
de
1963 la plupart de nos concitoyens
avaient encore vécu ces guerres et nous
ne saurions être assez reconnaissant
pour ce traité de l'Élysée qui n'allait
pas de soi
la visite détail de Charles de Gaulle en
Allemagne en
1962 a été il y a aussi un grand jalon
lors de cette visite il avait déjà
souligné la nécessité de la coopération
entre la France et l'Allemagne
mesdames et messieurs
ce sont les innombrables contacts entre
nos concitoyens ce sont les jumelages ce
sont les échanges des jeunes la
coopération entre les entreprises qui
s'envoyaient décisifs pour cette amitié
en évidence à quel point l'esprit de ce
traité
a marqué aussi la vie de nos concitoyens
au quotidien
et je dois dire que ceci est
certainement notre plus grande conquête
nos devons renforcer notre capacité
d'agir notre capacité à réagir à la
guerre en
Ukraine tout ceci montre combien
importante est une Europe forte pour
notre sécurité commune mais il est
évident aussi que l'Union européenne
doit encore être davantage renforcer
pour pouvoir garantir sa sécurité
intérieure et extérieure
de ce fait nous devons voir ensemble
parler aussi de renforcement de nos
institutions c'est aussi une condition
sinequanone pour l'élargissement de
l'Union européenne je pense notamment
aussi à une politique commerciale
renforcée
qui favorise des échanges libres des
échanges verts des nouveaux marchés mais
qui garantit aussi la sécurité de nos
approvisionnements nota et qui réduit
nos dépendances c'est ce cas montrer
aussi cette guerre ce dernier mois
et bien sûr
il faut évoquer ici aussi
notre sécurité énergétique il y a le
changement climatique et la souveraineté
de l'Europe chers collègues
il nous faut être pragmatique dans cette
coopération mais il nous faut aussi nous
respecter il faut nous faire confiance
il faut faire preuve d'empathie et c'est
les deux pragmatiques et ce respect
mutuel qui forment la base pour un
avenir commun un avenir remarqué par
notre amitié une amitié que nous avons
construit patiemment au cours de ces 60
dernières années vivent l'amitié vive
l'Europe
Alexandre Loubet
Alexandre Loubet rassemblement national
rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
mesdames les présidentes du Bundes tag
et de l'Assemblée nationale chers
collègues parlementaires allemands et
français il y a 60 ans le général de
Gaulle signé avec le chancelier Adenauer
le traité de l'Élysée avec toute la
légitimité que lui donnait son rôle
historique et le soutien du peuple
français le chef de la France Libre acté
par ce traité la réconciliation entre
nous deux peuples après des siècles de
conflits qui ont affaibli notre
continent déchirés nos pays respectifs
entraîner la mort de millions de nos
compatriotes et briser tant de familles
de part et d'autre du Rhin comme député
de la Moselle je peux témoigner devant
l'histoire du précieux acquis que
constitue l'entente et la coopération
entre nos deux nations
nous devons célébrer cet accord
historique aujourd'hui notre
interdépendance économique est
essentielle aujourd'hui nos coopérations
sont denses et nos liens solides
aujourd'hui nous sommes forts de nos
influence culturelles et
civilisationsnelles réciproque mais
l'amitié n'exclut pas la franchise je ne
peux que féliciter les dirigeants
allemands de défendre les intérêts de
leur pays mais je déplore de voir nos
dirige de voir de nos dirigeants
français renoncés à défendre nos
intérêts le discours d'Emmanuel Macron
ce matin en témoigne en effet dans de
nombreux domaines bilatéraux comme ne
cesse de l'affirmer Marine Le Pen la
coopération franco-allemande se fait
malheureusement à sens unique en matière
d'énergie la France doit cesser
d'affaiblir son industrie nucléaire et
de payer la facture de la dépendance de
l'Allemagne au gaz nos entreprises et
les ménages français peuvent témoigner
de la contribution qui leur est imposée
elles peuvent témoigner de l'effort de
solidarité européenne qui leur est
imposé elles peuvent y contribuer mais
pas un importe quel prix alors mettons
fin aux règles absurdes du marché
européen de l'énergie et développons
ensemble des coopérations d'avenir comme
l'hydrogène en matière d'économie la
France transfère massivement ces
richesses vers l'Allemagne notre déficit
commercial dépasse en moyenne les 14
milliards d'euros par an soit
l'équivalent de dizaines de milliers
d'emplois et de centaines d'usines
délocalisées nous devons travailler
ensemble pour mettre fin à se
déséquilibre économique en matière de
défense la France ne doit pas renoncer à
son indépendance l'Allemagne a fait le
choix de l'OTAN comme pilier de sa
politique de défense elle a fait le
choix d'acheter américain plutôt que
français pour ses équipements militaires
soit mais il est donc absurde que les
successeurs du Rafale et du Charles
Leclerc véritable réussite nationale qui
équipe armées et s'exporte à l'étranger
soit dilué dans un projet
franco-allemand qui fragilise la
souveraineté industrielle française en
matière de politique étrangère la France
n'a pas à offrir ses atouts
diplomatiques ni à l'Allemagne ni à
l'Union européenne si nous positions
peuvent évidemment être discutés
concerté coordonnées
notre pays doit conserver son siège
permanent au Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU dans la droite ligne de la
politique du général de Gaulle notre
relation doit être fondée sur la
réciprocité et la symétrie
pour coopérer tout en préservant nos
souveraineté respectives nous donnions
devrait d'abord compter sur leur propre
force le génie et la personnalité de
leur peuple nos donations devraient
travailler à égalité sur des projets
concrets agir pour le bien commun de
l'Europe et du monde nous donnons
ensemble
œuvrer pour la paix face à la guerre qui
frappe à nouveau notre continent nous
devons faire raisonner partout en Europe
le traité de réconciliation que nous
célébrons aujourd'hui plus que jamais ce
traité symbolise un espoir pour la paix
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
mon exemple qu'il est très très
important de maîtriser le français je
m'excuse de mes difficultés en la
matière je voudrais rendre la présidence
maintenant à Madame à ma collègue madame
Braun Pivet
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Katarina drogue pour le groupe Bounty
snowet pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
je chers collègues chers amis c'est pour
moi grand honneur de pouvoir reprendre
la parole devant cet assemblée
aujourd'hui et je voudrais vous en
remercier y est très sincèrement et je
voudrais également remercier nos
assistants nos collaborateurs qui nous
ont accompagnés dans l'organisation de
cette manifestation
[Applaudissements]
notre rencontre entre nos deux
parlements aux gens réduit est un signal
fort c'est un signal aussi en faveur de
l'Europe
je suis né en
1985 et je fais donc partie de la
génération pour laquelle l'Europe allait
déjà de soi c'était une Europe des
frontières ouvertes
la réunification allemande pour moi
était une évidence ainsi que l'amitié
franco-allemand de lorsque les collègues
durent et meurent ont pris la parole
je me suis rappelé que à mon époque cela
ne faisait pas de différence du fait de
savoir si j'étais allemande ou française
nous avions à l'époque discuter du rap
nous avions discuté de nos amitiés et
donc ça c'était les sujets qui nous
préoccupaient à l'époque donc pour une
jeunesse pour qui cette Europe elle est
de soi
mais c'était peut-être aussi une erreur
de ma génération peut-être que nous
avions trop facilement considéré que
tout cela va de soi orge l'époque
aquatuelle nous montre que tout ceci
n'est pas tout à fait naturel nous
voyons à nouveau la menace de la guerre
nous voyons que nous devons protéger nos
acquis aussi à une époque où les
nationalismes et les populismes gagnent
de nouveau en Europe
je dois dire que je m'excuse aussi du
fait qu'un extrémiste de droite allemand
est pris la parole ici dans cette
émission
[Applaudissements]
notre travail en faveur de l'Europe
suppose aussi que nous fassions preuve
d'esprit critique et si nous considérons
ce que nous avons fait au cours de la
pandémie
nous devons constater il y a que nous
avons eu un certain repli national à
cette époque que les frontières se sont
quelque peu refermés et je l'espère que
l'avenir nous allons trouver davantage
de réponse communes face à de telles
difficultés
[Applaudissements]
de solutions nationales ou de solutions
européennes alors il nous faut songer à
la lutte contre le changement climatique
nous sommes tous concernés en France
nous avons vu des périodes de sécheresse
de manque d'eau en Allemagne nous avait
eu des inondations dévastatrices nous
avons tous été concernés par les
conséquences de ce changement climatique
et je suis heureuse de constater il y a
que beaucoup ont évoqué aujourd'hui
cette lutte contre le changement
climatique et c'est notre tâche commune
c'est notre tâche nous l'attache aussi
de notre jeunesse et nous espérons que
le Parlement français et le parlement
allemand pourront davantage coopérer
pour relever ce défi qui est un défi
majeur pour nous et pour les générations
à venir merci beaucoup ma chère
collègues
et la parole est pour finir madame
Sandra weather pour le FDP
mesdames les présidentes prend Pivet et
basse chez collègues français et
allemand mesdames et messieurs
c'est une grande conviction que l'unité
de l'Europe est la meilleure chose qui
nous pouvait arriver et l'amitié
franco-allemand et le cœur est comme il
a dit monsieur le Président tout à
l'heure ce sont les deux âmes dans la
même poitrine et je pense cette base est
vraiment justement le traité de lisez et
donc
on célèbre ça aujourd'hui avec un grand
bonnet avec beaucoup de plaisir moi
comme franco-allemande serait pas ici
tel quel sans se traiter parce qu'en
fait je trouvais mon mari en France
grâce à un échange j'ai une famille
franco-allemande avec des enfants qui
ont les deux nationalités comme moi et
je pense ça c'est la preuve que ce
traité a bien fonctionné et que c'est un
grand
et je pense que
d'être une franco-allemande avec tous
les droits et avec toutes les
obligations qui sont liées et il y a de
me sentir investi de la mission de
renforcer les liens entre nos deux pays
nos deux pays qui sont envoyés
d'économies majeures de l'Europe et qui
sont de ce fait aussi appelés à
concevoir l'avenir de notre continent et
de protéger nos démocraties lorsque on
essaye d'affaiblir l'Union européenne de
la fragmentée alors la France et
l'Allemagne doivent se serrer les coudes
et je m'engage à se faire aussi dans le
cadre de l'assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande il est très important
que nous puissions discuter de questions
stratégiques pour l'Europe et que nous
puissions renforcer notre alliance
surtout au vu de la guerre qui sévit
actuellement sur notre continent pour
pouvoir relever ce défi nos deux pays
ont en 2019
confortés aussi par le traité de
Aix-la-Chapelle notre coopération on
crée l'Assemblée parlementaire il y a
franco-allemande et ont décidé de
renforcer notre politique sécuritaire il
importe maintenant d'agir et de
favoriser un partenariat encore plus
solide entre nous deux pays pour pouvoir
mener à bien sécurité interne et
extérieure et pour concevoir une
identité de défense commune
notre rôle en matière de politique de
défense et de politique étrangère et de
l'actualité absolument brûlante au vu de
la guerre en Ukraine il s'agit
maintenant d'agir en commun il ne faut
plus hésiter il ne faut plus faire
preuve
d'opportunistes ou d'hésitation en tant
que nation en tant que société non
devons nous engager plus que jamais vive
la France vive l'Allemagne côte à côte
toujours ensemble
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue
mes chers collègues nous voici parvenus
au terme de ce débat je voudrais
remercier particulièrement madame Barbel
base d'avoir présidé cette séance à mes
côtés je voudrais tous vous remercier
des deux collègues des deux rives du
Rhin pour tous vos mots toutes vos
histoires partagées aussi on voit qu'il
y a eu beaucoup d'amour aussi dans cette
amitié
franco-allemande et
[Musique]
je crois que nous garderons tous dans
dans nos mémoires cette belle journée
que nous avons partagée également nous
avons tous une conscience aiguë du
devoir et de la responsabilité qui sont
les nôtres à présent de continuer à
porter haut cette amitié
franco-allemande de l'affaire vivre de
la faire vivre avec eux pour l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens nous avons tous qui
sommes ici réunis à quel point elle est
primordiale pour la paix pour l'avenir
de l'Europe et donc nous comptons sur
vous sur chacun d'entre vous merci
beaucoup la séance est levée
et voilà donc pour cette séance inédite
particulière bien évidemment d'échanges
entre parlementaires français et
allemand en ce 60e anniversaire de la
signature du traité de l'Élysée Marco
pommier est avec nous ainsi que Richard
Werly merci de m'accompagner Richard
jusqu'au bout de cette journée voilà
chronique régulier sur la chaîne
parlementaire et correspondant parisien
France Europe d'ailleurs du quotidien
suisse Blic petit débrief avec vous
marquo vous avez suivi de près cette
séance d'échanges quand retenir
précisément et bien écoutez Myriam
c'était une séance parlementaire
franco-allemande particulière
puisqu'elle a été présidée par deux
femmes dans un premier temps par Yelle
brun Pivet présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale puis dans un deuxième temps
par barbelbass présidente du booten stag
allemand les deux présidentes qui ont
entamé cette séance par une déclaration
commune elles ont rappelé elles vont
elles ont voulu elles veulent renforcer
elles ont indiqué qu'elle voulait
renforcer pardonnez-moi la coopération
entre nos deux pays sur l'égalité
homme-femme sur l'enseignement du
français et de l'allemand aussi dans nos
deux pays respectifs je suis désolé on
va donner la priorité au direct parce
qu'on voulait vous faire vivre cette
image inédite regardez les deux
présidents des deux chambres barbelbass
de Bundes
Pivet pour l'Assemblée nationale qui
vont signer en commun un document une
forme de livre d'or est-ce que Valérie
Brochard est en direct et regarde cette
image avec nous non elle elle pourrait
venir alors voilà on va on va essayer de
voir ce qui se joue voilà ce ce document
de déclaration commune qui est montrée
aux caméras
et qui vient célébrer bien évidemment à
nouveau
l'amitié la solidité de la relation
franco-allemande dans son versant
parlementaire dont on a vu qu'il était
riche et dense aujourd'hui
photo de famille
et photos de présidente
voilà est-ce que Marco pommier est resté
avec nous
parce que j'étais bien désolée tout à
l'heure de
l'interrompre pendant qu'on
va finir de d'accompagner
deux femmes ces deux présidentes Marco
on vous écoute et pardonnez-moi à
nouveau je vous ai interrompu
rappelez-nous alors les temps forts de
cette séance de questions
franco-allemande dans l'hémicycles oui
Myriam j'étais en train de j'étais en
train de vous dire que les deux femmes
ont entamé cette séance par une
déclaration commune elles ont expliqué
qu'elle voulait renforcer la coopération
entre nos deux pays sur l'égalité
homme-femmes sur l'enseignement du
français aussi et de l'allemand dans nos
deux pays respectifs une séance
parlementaire franco-allemande durant
laquelle ils ont rappelé les
parlementaires l'importance de la
cohésion de nos deux pays face au défi
de notre temps face au réchauffement
climatique face à la guerre en Ukraine
aussi à silukraine tombe c'est l'Europe
qui sera menacée à déclaré le député
français Frédéric valthou alors il y a
quand même un petit moment de tension de
froid dans l'hémicycle lors de la prise
de parole d'un député allemand du groupe
AFD c'est l'extrême droite allemande
celui-ci a dénoncé l'idéologie du
réchauffement
des migrations massives en Europe
l'accès libre à l'avortement en dehors
de ce moment on peut dire que les
discussions ont fait relativement
consensus sur les bancs de l'Assemblée
nationale entre la France et l'Allemagne
la journée s'achève à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a encore un temps
d'échange important tout de même à
suivre sur LCP Marco exactement là les
deux présidentes viennent de signer la
déclaration commune qui a été discutée
dans l'hémicycle cet après-midi et puis
juste après elles vont revenir dans
l'hémicycle pour discuter avec des
jeunes Français et des jeunes Allemands
des échanges qui devraient durer environ
45 minutes Myriam et on suivra pas parce
que c'est aussi important cette
transmission de cette amitié
franco-allemande à la jeune génération
la jeune génération voilà qui bientôt ne
connaîtra plus les derniers survivants
de la Shoah les dernières grandes
victimes de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et donc cette cette mémoire et la
construction même de ce couple doit être
évidemment
transmis qu'est-ce que vous retenez vous
Richard wernez vous qui avez suivi
depuis le début à la fois les deux
discours le président français le
chancelier allemand à la Sorbonne et
puis c'est tant d'échange où on se rend
compte que ce lien est très très solide
oui c'était une journée extrêmement
symbolique je crois qu'il faut le
rappeler elle était faite pour ça elle
était faite pour redire que ce traité de
l'Elysée est un socle qu'il a été signé
il y a 60 ans parce que le général de
Gaulle écondra d'adenaauer voulait un
destin commun entre la France et
l'Allemagne donc ça je crois que c'est
mission accomplies au niveau des
symboles le fait que la présidente du
bunderstag est présidé la séance à
l'Assemblée au final ce sont quand même
des images fortes après il y a quelques
petits blancs on pourrait dire ou
quelques petits points de suspension
d'abord on l'a dit ce matin une
déclaration des déclarations d'intention
des déclarations d'amour mais pas
tellement de preuves d'amour en tout cas
on les attend on verra si la conférence
de presse d'une part d'Emmanuel Macron
et de et du chancelier de sol ça portera
des réponses cet après-midi par exemple
en prenant un peu de distance je suis
assez surpris de l'hémicycle
relativement vide je trouve que c'est un
peu dommage que pour un tel moment un
moment aussi solennel l'hémicycle est
quand même été relativement dégarnie
Marco parlait de la prise de parole du
député de la FD moi j'ai entendu
également la prise de parole d'un député
du rassemblement national alors là on a
deux points de vue soit on retient la
provocation ou l'élément disons de
défiance de ces députés envers l'amitié
franco-allemande le député du
rassemblement national a quand même
insisté sur les logiques nationales des
deux pays soit on se dit c'est la
réalité du paysage politique il était
normal d'entendre ces voix là aussi
parce que dans les deux pays en France
en Allemagne et bien c'est qu'en
politique ont une grande importance et
il façonne aussi l'opinion la réalité du
traité de l'Élysée 60 ans après c'est
qu'il faut savoir le maintenir alors que
dans l'opinion publique il y a des blocs
on va dire identitaires je ne sais pas
quel autre mot employé débloque
nationaux populistes qui au fond si
c'est à eux qu'on confiait la tâche de
le rossigner aujourd'hui je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il le fasse on va reprendre la
direction des quatre colonnes à
l'Assemblée nationale Valérie Brochard
vous êtes aux côtés d'une très grande
européenne d'une germanophone aussi
puisqu'il s'agit de brigitte Klinkert
député qui a longtemps présidé le
département du radio-rhin absolument
Myriam et vous êtes également madame
klinkerte présidente du bureau de
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande alors barbelbass dans
son propos introductif a déclaré ceci
nous sommes très conscients du fait que
nous vivons une période de profonde
rupture est-ce que la déclaration
commune qui est en train d'être signée
qui vient d'être signé peut réduire voir
faire disparaître ces ruptures
vous savez l'amitié franco-allemande est
une histoire qui a maintenant 60 ans
c'est ce que nous fêtons aujourd'hui et
l'amitié franco-allemande est profonde
lorsqu'on est amis il y a des moments où
on s'entend tout va bien et on n'a pas
besoin d'être d'accord sur tout le temps
l'essentiel c'est de continuer à se voir
de discuter et d'essayer de trouver des
consensus et c'est ce que nous essayons
de faire en particulier à travers le
travail de l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande qui a été mise en place
en 2019 nous avons donc aujourd'hui
quatre ans je tiens à dire que c'est la
seule assemblée binationale au monde qui
rassemble donc 50 députés français et 50
députés allemands c'est une avancée
politique énorme et je crois pouvoir
dire que le monde entier regarde la
France et l'Allemagne ce qui se passe
ici est juste unique nous étions des
ennemis pendant des décennies et là nous
sommes les meilleurs amis et nous sommes
un modèle pour le monde entier et
pourtant Valérie Rabault votre collègue
du Parti socialiste évoquait la parole
forte sur la guerre en Ukraine est-ce
qu'elle manque cette voix commune en
fait regardez ce qui s'est passé que ce
soit pendant la crise du covid que ce
soit pour la crise de l'énergie que ce
soit la crise en Ukraine et bien on a
toujours réussi à travailler ensemble il
y a avancer ensemble vous savez moi je
suis élu en Alsace nous avions connu une
crise du covid terrible au printemps
2020 et bien aujourd'hui je tiens à le
dire c'est grâce à l'aide de nos de nos
voisins notamment allemand que nous nous
en sommes sortis et ça je ne l'oublierai
jamais la coopération franco-allemande a
sauvé des vies merci beaucoup merci
Madame kingers Merci à VOUS Valérie
Brochard évidemment la guerre en Ukraine
est dans toutes les quêtes elle vient
percuter cette anniversaire vous avez le
sentiment qu'au fond elle a été assez
présente aujourd'hui beaucoup beaucoup
de pays de journalistes aussi l'opinion
mondiale à temps de ce couple
franco-allemand peut être une aide plus
massive sur le plan militaire est-ce que
c'était le jour au fond pour parler de
cela ou au contraire on peut comprendre
l'idée d'une parenthèse pour
l'anniversaire non je crois pas que
c'était une parenthèse d'ailleurs ce
matin on l'a bien vu l'Ukraine a quand
même été présente dans les deux discours
à chaque fois pour dire la même chose
c'est-à-dire que le soutien l'Ukraine
sera inébranlable au lave Scholl ça
dénoncé l'impérialisme de Vladimir
Poutine je crois même qu'il a dit qu'il
ne passera pas je sais pas si c'était
l'explosion exacte jusqu'à la victoire
le soutien jusqu'à la victoire donc elle
était présente après fallait-il
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait l'annonce de
nouvelles modalités d'aide on pense
évidemment au char allemand puisque
c'est le sujet actuel ça ça se discute
on peut penser que oui parce que le
moment justement était approprié pour
lui donner un écho massif ça sera posée
d'ailleurs exactement
cool que ce n'était pas le lieu parce
que le chancelier allemand est président
de la République était à la Sorbonne que
c'était davantage un discours prospectif
donc je crois que ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que sur l'Ukraine il y a une
volonté commune d'avancer côte à côte et
alors après par contre reste une
question et cette question là elle n'a
pour l'instant pas été traité elle a pas
de réponse c'est qu'elles vont être les
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine sur
l'Europe et comment les deux pays vont
réagir parce que c'est une chose que
Paris et Berlin disent voilà ce qu'on
veut puis après les circonstances vont
décider Brigitte Linka parlait du covid
il y a quand même un moment donné où ça
a tangué sérieusement donc est-ce que le
navire franco-allemand aujourd'hui est
encore suffisamment solide pour
affronter les tempêtes qui vont venir et
est-ce que les autres pays européens
vont considérer ce couple comme toujours
le grand moteur en Europe tout à fait ça
je crois que
pour l'instant on a la volonté au fond
des deux capitaines du navire
franco-allemand d'avancer ensemble mais
les tempêtes ne sont pas finies et vous
parliez ce matin Myriam de la Pologne
par exemple le rôle d'un pays comme la
Pologne le rôle des États-Unis on en a
parlé aussi qui ont une vue bien
particulière de la situation et puis
quand même ceux qui peuvent de Vladimir
Poutine parce qu'il y a un moment donné
où les les coûts portés par Vladimir
Poutine à l'Europe pourrait amener ce
navire franco-allemand à Tanguay merci
beaucoup Richard Verline m'avoir
accompagné regardez ces images on va
tout de suite rejoindre l'émission qu'on
est dans quelque chose de beaucoup plus
proche il y a le brune Pivet face à la
jeunesse assise devant la représentation
nationale en tout cas évidemment le
temps d'une minute incarné par ces
jeunes aujourd'hui mais surtout demain
ce sera de votre responsabilité c'est
vous qui devrez la faire vivre et d'ores
et déjà vous la faites vivre en faisant
des études en nouant un lien profond les
uns avec les autres et entre nos deux
pays donc merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
d'être associé à cette journée ça doit
être un peu impressionnant pour vous
parce que vous êtes assis à la place des
députés ça n'est pas si fréquent que ça
que l'on accepte dans cette émission des
personnes qui n'ont pas été élu et quel
siège sur les bancs des parlementaires
et donc je pense que vous mesurez le
moment que vous êtes en train de vivre
en tout cas je l'espère et j'espère
qu'il donnera aussi envie à certains
d'entre vous de vous engager dans la vie
politique et dans la vie démocratique
parce que on a besoin de toutes les
énergies donc avant que nous échangions
je vais donner la parole à berbel pour
qu'elle vous adresse un mot d'accueil et
puis nous pourrons après lancer la
discussion
je ne vais pas dire tant de choses de
manière à ce que nous puissions utiliser
le temps que nous avons pour échanger
j'ai peut-être envie de vous demander de
quelle manière aussi vous avez vécu
cette journée cet anniversaire
je suis
ravi de vous voir sinon nombreux
c'est vrai que
mais peut-être que comme vous l'avez dit
oui nous avons de futurs députés ici
dans cette salle nous ne savons pas mais
c'est vrai qu'au bundesta que en
Allemagne aussi nous avons des journées
qui s'appellent jeunesse et Parlement où
nous faisons également ce genre
d'échanges et c'est d'ailleurs un groupe
et le seul groupe de jeunes qui a le
droit d'être présent dans le bundestal
donc c'est quelque chose d'un peu
exceptionnel c'est vrai je suis ravi de
vous voir avec nous
et voilà je pense qu'il est temps
maintenant d'utiliser notre entre temps
et puis de changer merci beaucoup pour
votre présence
[Applaudissements]
te lancer pour justement nous dire
comment il ou elle a ressenti cette
journée
et qu'est-ce que ça lui évoque c'est
toujours très difficile pour le premier
de parler alors vas-y je sais pas si
vous avez prévu des micro si tout est
parfait ici
vous m'entendez ah oui
je suis très honoré de
je suis très honoré de pouvoir être ici
aujourd'hui et j'apprécie réellement que
sa journée était organisée parce que
l'amitié franco-allemande ça m'est très
cher parce que je suis personnellement
j'ai les deux nations franco-allemande
et je viens de Strasbourg donc une
région frontalière où c'est très
important puisque je vais au lycée à
Strasbourg mais habite à Kehl donc de
l'autre côté du Rhin donc tous les jours
je passe la frontière tous les jours je
vis l'amitié franco-allemande et donc ça
m'est très important ça m'est très
important et si on aurait pu être ici
aujourd'hui avec vous tous voilà
pour respecter la parité est-ce qu'une
jeune femme voudrait prendre la parole
pour nous dire que ce que cette journée
lui a évoqué mademoiselle
personnellement je suis également très
honorée de pouvoir participer à cette
journée c'est une occasion très
particulière et je suis absolument pas
franco-allemande de naissance je suis
juste française mais je me suis vraiment
prise de passion pour la langue
allemande et la culture et j'ai vraiment
je suis allé à Berlin c'était j'ai
trouvé que c'était une ville incroyable
et je suis vraiment très heureuse qu'on
puisse faire entendre ces deux nations
et les unir pour une meilleure entente
économique etc
le micro qu'est-ce que si tu avais un
rêve ou une baguette magique qu'est-ce
que dans va lui laisser le micro
monsieur s'il vous plaît
qu'est-ce que si tu avais une baguette
magique si tu pouvais former devant nous
un rêve quel serait-il par rapport
justement à cette amitié
franco-allemande et à cette à l'avenir
de nos deux pays
déjà peut-être essayer de faire renouer
les jeunes avec l'allemand en France
notamment en Allemagne je sais pas trop
comment ça se passe mais en France en
tout cas dans mon collège il y avait
très peu de lycéens enfin de collégiens
qui choisissait de faire allemand on
était un quart je pense même pas et je
pense que c'est important de montrer que
c'est une langue qui est quand même très
belle contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser que c'est une culture qui est
très passionnante et que il faudrait
vraiment essayer de montrer ça à tout le
monde et il faudrait que les gens s'en
aperçoivent faudrait ouvrir les yeux aux
jeunes surtout
[Applaudissements]
peut-être y a-t-il quelques questions ou
remarque critiques comment comment
avez-vous ressenti cette journée je sais
que certains d'entre vous étaient
présents tout à l'heure
alors bonjour
une occasion parce qu'on va se donner
les lignes directrices pour le futur
donc c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
j'ai une question plus technique sur
donc l'évolution des liens
franco-allemand qui est ce matin on a eu
les enfin oui les dirigeants exécutifs
en même temps que les dirigeants
parlementaires donc les législatives
quelle est la différence
dans les actions qui seront prises
ensuite
par rapport à l'exécutif et au
législatif c'est à dire pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui fait un événement
particulièrement législatif au Parlement
avec les deux présidentes de Parlement
franco-allemand
en plus des discours exécutifs de ce
matin voilà quelle est l'apport
supplémentaire
c'est ma question
je vais commencer à répondre
en tout cas pour au nom du bundestal
allemand je peux dire qu'il était
important que nous nous rencontrions au
niveau du Parlement parce que nous
impulsons si je puis dire les futurs
lignes et nous nous sommes réunis dans
cette hémicycle cette après-midi parce
que nous avons une assemblée des
parlementaires en France en Allemagne
enfin franco-allemande depuis 2019 de
manière à pouvoir apporter quelque chose
au gouvernement donc il y a cette cette
institution cette instance très
particulière qui n'existe que entre la
France et l'Allemagne qui est nourrit on
discute alors bon aujourd'hui il y a pas
eu beaucoup de discussions c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu des apports des
contributions en raison de cette
anniversaire et de cette de célébrations
mais nous discutons comme un assez
vivement donc on invite des ministres
hommes et femmes ont leur demande de
rendre compte sur leur position de nous
les expliquer et nous essayons aussi de
mettre en oeuvre bien sûr enfin d'abord
de parvenir à un accord vous avez vu
qu'il y a beaucoup de fractions
politiques différentes mais il s'agit de
trouver le dénominateur commun qui
pourra quand tout va bien ensuite être
transformé en loi
c'est pour cela que nous avons fêté
ensemble mais il y a aussi des des
points qui
nécessitent quelquefois le soutien voir
la prise de contrôle
je suis entièrement d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire berbel je voudrais ajouter
que les relations diplomatiques les
relations entre les pays elles doivent
se nouer à tous les niveaux et que il
est très important que
le Parlement puisse avoir une action
diplomatique elle est différente et
complémentaire de celle qu'on les
exécutifs à travers les ministres les
ministres des Affaires étrangères
ministre des affaires européennes et
évidemment le chef de l'État et les
relations parlementaires apportent ont
en cela quelque chose de très singulier
c'est d'une part qu'elles vont concerner
l'ensemble des groupes politiques alors
que en général l'exécutif ne va
représenter qu'une tendance politique au
Parlement nous avons toutes les
tendances politiques réunies et vous
avez bien pu entendre aujourd'hui des
opinions très différentes et très
diverses s'exprimer mais ces opinions
très diverses qui elle représente les
opinions de nos peuples et donc en cela
c'est très intéressant d'avoir cette
relation parlementaire en plus parce que
c'est l'expression directe de la
diversité que sont nos populations
qu'elles soient allemandes ou françaises
et donc ça donne quelque chose bien qui
correspond davantage à la réalité à la
diversité j'ajoute après que nous avons
effectivement l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande nous avons aussi nos
commissions qui vont pouvoir nouer des
liens privilégiés et tu vois aujourd'hui
les commissions de la défense par
exemple ont décidé de travailler en
commun et donc là c'est vraiment des
parlementaires qui sont spécialisés sur
un sujet qui vont pouvoir échanger
discuter et voir comment ils peuvent se
projeter et projeter nos parlements dans
l'avenir et ça c'est très important
aussi pour nos parlements pour renforcer
le rôle de nos parlements mais aussi
pour le pouvoir exécutif qui est éclairé
sur la façon et le travail que faut
réalise les parlements différents donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
complémentaire et je pense que c'était
très important aujourd'hui d'avoir ces
deux cet événement conjoint avec ce
moment ensemble à la Sorbonne et après
deux séquences une à l'Assemblée
nationale et une analysée avec le
Conseil des ministres franco-allemand je
pense que grâce à ça on a pu montrer la
complétude de la relation
franco-allemande et je crois que ça
renforce la symbolique de cette
célébration de cet anniversaire
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ou
d'autres interventions mademoiselle
déjà bonjour et merci de nous accueillir
ici c'est très gentil de prendre sur
votre temps pour pour communiquer avec
les jeunes
OK
et du coup moi j'avais une question qui
traite un peu votre vision globale de la
vie politique actuelle en fait c'est la
mesure dans laquelle les événements
passés entre la France et l'Allemagne
influencent-ils votre conception
actuelle de la politique et les
décisions que vous êtes amené à prendre
je crois que les le passé
faites nous nous appelle à nous dépasser
et c'est ça aussi la célébration du
traité de l'Elysée ce n'est jamais
facile de faire la paix c'est
nécessairement c'est un acte de courage
parce que on fait la paix avec quelqu'un
qui a plus ou moins rêves échéance était
son ennemi et il faut être en capacité
de se dépasser de ce de se dire que et
bien il y a quelque chose de beaucoup
plus grand que la rancune de beaucoup
plus fort que la haine et que oui
construire ensemble quelque chose à
l'aide de l'avant main dans la main et
bien c'est plus difficile mais c'est
beaucoup plus fort beaucoup plus
profitable pour nos pays et pour
pour la paix et c'est vrai que
finalement l'histoire elle est pleine de
ces personnes qui ont été capables de se
surpasser et en fait moi c'est ça que
j'ai en héritage et je me dis il faut
savoir dépasser ce que ce qu'on pourrait
avoir finalement par instinct ou par
facilité il faut être capable de se dire
que on doit faire différemment et après
il faut être capable d'entraîner
d'entraîner des peuples parce que il ne
suffit pas de d'avoir cette volonté là
il faut la faire partager cette volonté
il faut évidemment la faire partager à
son partenaires mais il faut les faire
partager au peuple et c'est ce qui est
peut-être le plus difficile mais je
crois que c'est ça qui va nous apporter
la paix c'est ça qui nous apporte c'est
60 ans du traité de l'olylisée qu'on
célèbre aujourd'hui et donc en tant que
femme politique moi c'est cela que ça
m'inspire cette nécessité absolue de se
dépasser pour nos valeurs et pour ceux
en quoi nous croyons
pour vous parler de mon ressenti ce
matin nos avons rappelé que l'Europe a
été il y a caractérisé par deux guerres
mondiales aussi parlé de Simone Veil qui
a perdu ses parents son frère pendant
l'Holocauste et j'ai parlé aussi il y a
des crimes du cette période de
l'histoire et malgré ces événements ou
ainsi ma nouvelle a tendu la main aux
Allemands et je suis profondément
reconnaissante pour cela et c'est aussi
un rappel permanent donc il faut se
rappeler de l'histoire il faut se
rappeler les événements à passer et les
dépasser et la guerre d'agression menée
par la Russie au sein de l'Europe est
une guerre que je n'aurais pas pensé
possible car je fais partie d'une
génération qui pensait profondément que
nous pourrions préserver la paix sans
les armes or maintenant nous avons une
guerre nous devons soutenir l'Ukraine
avec tous les moyens et compris avec nos
forces armées et il y a ceci nous
rappelle que des événements pareils sont
toujours possibles et ceux-ci
m'incite aussi à vouloir toujours
renforcer notre amitié qui est d'éviter
d'en arriver au point où on ne peut plus
se parler car lorsque on arrive à ce
point là on a tendance à passer à
l'étape suivante à savoir à la guerre or
c'est ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui au
sein de l'Europe une guerre au sein de
l'Europe et ceci nous confortent dans
notre position à savoir cette amitié qui
est née à partir il y a d'une situation
horrible est une amitié que nous devons
honorer à tout et l'Allemagne est
profondément reconnaissante pour ce
faire et il faut se rappeler que
toujours ces événements aujourd'hui nous
avons un relevé beaucoup de défis cette
guerre le changement climatique la
souveraineté énergétique les problèmes
économiques mais aussi les
problématiques sociales et aujourd'hui
nous avons entendu que les différents
groupes au sein de nos assemblées
parlementaires ne partagent pas
forcément les mêmes approches et cela
fait partie du quotidien d'un Parlement
mais il faut toujours se rappeler qu'il
faut miser sur le positif malgré nos
différences et c'est ce qui nous fera
avancer en Europe et donc si je me pose
la question à savoir que signifiait
cette amitié pour nous c'est surtout que
nous avons des histoires différentes
mais que nous avons beaucoup beaucoup de
points communs et c'est un acquis
ici présent aujourd'hui
apprennent l'allemand et que davantage
de lycée allemand après ne le français
et c'est quelque chose qui a été encore
une fois signalée ici donc j'ai deux
questions à ce propos premièrement
comment voulez-vous motiver concrètement
les lycéens d'apprendre
l'allemand en France et le français en
Allemagne
et
comment en fait inciter il y a les
lycéens d'apprendre par exemple
l'allemand plutôt que l'Espagnol qui à
terme risque d'être plus intéressant
parce que davantage parler de par le
monde
permettez-moi de répondre répondre en
premier c'est évidemment compliqué parce
que nous avons une politique de
l'éducation et qui est décidé en
Allemagne par 16 blender différents donc
ce n'est pas la fédération qui est
souveraine en matière d'éducation en
d'autres termes nous devons convaincre
nos linders
linguistique dans les écoles proposées
donc au lycéen
différentes langues anglais le français
l'espagnol voire deux langues beaucoup
de lycéens ont tendance aussi à choisir
des langues qui leur ressemblent moins
difficile
et je sais aussi que beaucoup de
Français disent que la langue allemande
est particulièrement difficiles et les
jeunes auront peut-être tendance à aussi
à choisir une langue qui leur ouvre
beaucoup de portes au niveau
internationales savoir anglais ou
l'espagnol mais nous pouvons bien sûr
œuvrer de façon à ce que les enseignants
proposent
l'allemand en France et le français en
Allemagne nous l'essayons
aussi au sein de nos jumelages nous
avons 2200 jumelages et dans les villes
jumelles nous pouvons aussi mettre
l'accent sur l'apprentissage de la
langue on a parlé aujourd'hui à maintes
reprises des échanges de lycéens des
échanges de jeunes nous avons entendu
dire aussi que dans certains cas cela
même conduit des couples à se former
donc nous pourrions utiliser aussi ce
cadre pour favoriser l'apprentissage de
nos langues réciproques et qui
donc leur donner aussi l'intérêt pour la
langue du partenaire
et je pense que ceux-ci serait un aspect
très important pour notre politique de
l'enseignement des langues mais comme je
l'ai déjà dit en Allemagne il faut en
convenir avec 16 blender
nous avons aussi nos régions
frontalières le Baden burtenberg la sœur
ou c'est peut-être plus facile parce que
plus proche de la France par exemple
vous venez de l'évoquer
dans les régions frontières mais pas que
de maîtriser la langue du partenaire
il faudrait vraiment proposer la langue
du partenaire au niveau donc de la
pédagogique dans nos écoles pour
compléter parce qu'on m'a donné des
chiffres parce qu'il faut effectivement
même si c'est quelque chose qui décroît
sur lequel il faut absolument faire un
effort considérable depuis que l'ophage
existe il y a eu presque 10 millions de
jeunes de nos deux pays qui ont
participé à des programmes d'échanges et
des programmes d'échanges il y en a eu
382 000 c'est dire à quel point quand
même les échanges entre nos deux
jeunesses sont nombreux et sont et sont
précieux c'est vrai que il faut
probablement agir davantage pour faire
en sorte que nos jeunes dans nos deux
pays choisissent l'apprentissage de
l'allemand il faut le faire à tous les
niveaux à mon sens pas seulement
au collège ou au lycée mais le faire par
le rendre accessible dès le plus jeune
âge et poursuivre l'effort après lors
des formations professionnelles lors des
études supérieures pour multiplier les
occasions pour les jeunes de nos deux
pays d'apprendre cette langue et de
participer à des échanges des stages des
formations des apprentissages etc il ne
faut je crois négliger aucune piste pour
effectivement renforcer cela on voit
bien à quel point effectivement la
connaissance d'une même langue la
connaissance commune les histoires qui
se croisent s'entremêlent font la force
de ce couple franco-allemand et la
langue évidemment y participe grandement
alors à côté à notre droite
bonjour
mesdames le président donc je pense que
cette journée nous montre à quel point
le l'amitié franco-allemande c'est une
réalité aujourd'hui
et que du coup par rapport à ça j'avais
une question
c'est si nous voulons aujourd'hui une
Europe forte de façon internationale
est-ce que vous pensez
possible et souhaitable que cette amitié
franco-allemande devienne une amitié
européenne et si oui comment
voilà
que nous ne sommes pas les seuls à
construire l'Europe
il a été dit à maintes reprises que nous
sommes le moteur ou la locomotive de
l'Europe nous pouvons évidemment faire
beaucoup en faveur de l'Europe mais nous
ne sommes pas seuls nous pouvons donner
des impulsions nous pouvons définir les
grands sujets comme par exemple
changement de climat donc la
décarbonation de l'industrie etc on peut
essayer d'être exemplaire pour d'autres
pays européens
et c'est ce qu'on évoqué aussi le
chancelier et le président français à
savoir nous sommes une force d'impulsion
en Europe
sont deux pays forts l'Allemagne et la
France et qui peuvent servir aussi
d'exemples pour d'autres pays qui
peuvent donner une impulsion
[Musique]
en fait c'est serré les coudes
face à cette guerre d'agression et nous
devrions utiliser cette base pour
continuer à développer l'Europe car nous
devons gérer un certain nombre de
problèmes à savoir plus de cohésion
économique une meilleure politique en
matière de migration
par exemple l'Allemagne a été très
dépendante de la Russie en ce qui
concerne les énergies maintenant nous
devons nous demander comment nous
pouvons en commun par exemple développer
davantage les énergies renouvelables
comment pouvons-nous davantage affirmer
notre souveraineté face à la Chine par
exemple donc
nous ne pouvons pas agir seul mais nous
pouvons jouer le rôle de locomotive pour
entraîner les autres voilà je n'ai pas
grand chose à ajouter en fait l'un n'est
pas exclusif de l'autre et ça n'est pas
parce que tu as des relations
privilégiées avec un pays ou avec un cas
que tu n'en as pas avec d'autres ce qui
est important c'est de construire des
relations privilégiées et de continuer à
construire une Europe on a bien vu avec
les différentes crises qui a évoqué
berbel que ce soit la crise énergétique
la crise sanitaire aujourd'hui la crise
avec la guerre c'est l'Europe qui a
réussi à montrer un visage uni et
apporter une réponse forte pour autant à
l'intérieur de l'Europe tout est très
complexe nous sommes 27 et il est
important de savoir que il y a des pays
sur lesquels l'on peut particulièrement
s'appuyer parce qu'on partage la même
vision qu'il y a des pays qui peuvent
exercer effectivement ce rôle de
leadership ou de locomotive c'est un
devoir aussi de le faire quand les temps
sont difficiles autrement s'il n'y a pas
ça l'Europe après ça devient finalement
le plus petit des nominateur commun et
ça n'est finalement qu'un marché de
marchandises et de personnes et nous
avons une ambition beaucoup plus grande
pour l'Europe et je crois que dans cette
ambition beaucoup plus grande que nous
portons pour l'Europe la France et
l'Allemagne ont un rôle à jouer
j'ai une question de la part de ou une
intervention de la part de ma chère
vice-présidente madame Fiat alors elle
n'est pas étudiante franco-allemande non
mais Elvis préside avec talent
l'Assemblée nationale avec mes côtés
donc je lui souhaite volontiers la
parole
merci madame la Présidente ça va être
très bref
j'ai la chance d'avoir grandi en
Lorraine et d'avoir fait
partie de la dernière génération
ah pardon de la dernière l'une des
dernières générations qui faisait que
quand on habitait en Lorraine il fallait
étudier l'allemand en première langue
et j'ai pas envie avec tout le respect
que je vous dois mesdames les
présidentes de vous poser la question à
vous mais de poser parce que quand je
vois toute cette jeunesse sur nos bancs
la question à vous et de me dire que je
suis sûr que l'on va se recroiser d'ici
quelques années et de vous demander à
vous comment pourrions-nous faire pour
que
mes enfants
puisse étudier l'allemand comme moi il a
été de fait que en rentrant au collège
on me dise tu rentres en 6e tu vas
étudier l'allemand ce qui n'est plus le
cas actuellement
qu'est-ce que vous allez nous proposer
parce que on a beau y réfléchir je vous
le promets on y réfléchit on n'a pas
l'idée et si je vous demande cette
solution pour chez nous en France
globalement on va y réfléchir pour chez
vous en Allemagne pour qu'on étudie le
français
dans les régions frontalières mais pas
que voilà et que on se retrouve en
2033 et qu'on est trouver une solution
et voilà sans aucun manque de respect
pour vous mesdames les présidentes mais
si on pouvait sortir ce soir et demander
à cette nouvelle génération de trouver
cette solution ou si mesdames les
présidents vous avez la solution je la
prends non mais est-ce que quelqu'un
d'entre vous donc a des idées pour
booster l'apprentissage des langues
alors très rapidement on va faire
circuler le micro Caroline tu fais
passer aux différents et puis vous nous
donnez vos idées alors bonjour à tous
Nous je suis un élève du lycée
franco-allemand à Buc on est pas mal de
monde ici et je trouve que c'est dans ce
lycée là particulièrement bien fait
puisqu'on est en association avec
aujourd'hui trois lycées en Allemagne et
un autre as à Strasbourg en France et je
trouve que l'Allemand a été en fait
obligatoire dès la 6ème avec un Allemand
intensif par de à raison de 8 heures par
semaine donc on a dû beaucoup apprendre
dès le début mais en fait ça a été
accompagné de de beaucoup de sorties et
ça renforcé particulièrement la cohésion
au sein de la promo il y a eu aussi des
sorties l'année dernière par exemple à
Berlin on a eu systématiquement de la
cinquième jusqu'à la troisième à chaque
fois des correspondants et je trouve que
un lycée comme le lycée dans lequel on a
la chance de pouvoir évoluer qui intègre
en fait une partie de la culture
française une partie de la culture
allemande permet aussi de s'y intéresser
et d'évoluer plus en accord avec cette
amitié on a par exemple à bistry après
après le bac ou c'est une fête où on
charrie un petit peu les professeurs
où les lycéens charrient un petit peu
les professeurs et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne pratique pas du tout en
France et donc voilà faire tout ça ce
serait bien pour développer merci
beaucoup donc créer des lycées
spécifiques qui permettent
l'apprentissage pour tous les élèves de
ce lycée ça c'est une idée on a plus que
5 minutes me dit-on donc allez très vite
vas-y juste pour les mesures concrètes
je pense que si il est nécessaire de
commencer plus tôt dans l'école
maternelle dans l'école et du coup de
approfondir dans le lycée au collège et
justement de donner des opportunités ou
plus jeunes déjà
donc commencez l'apprentissage dès la
maternel Kindergarden alors vas-y
allez-y une des deux et puis à droite
bonjour à tous très rapidement je
voulais justement rebondir sur ce que ce
jeune homme vient de dire c'est
justement moi aussi en fin de primaire
vers le CM2 j'étais comme dans une
primaire et un collège public de
banlieue donc j'avais pas cette cet
apport de langue que par exemple le
lycée Buc va avoir pour ses élèves mais
cette présentation de la langue dès le
plus jeune âge peut apporter aussi
l'intérêt des élèves et un peu éveillé
leur curiosité et justement permettre à
la langue allemande mais aussi français
chez les Allemands vraiment de
s'exploiter de se découvrir
tout simplement merci
bah je viens du même lycée que la
personne qui vient de parler mais en
fait oui du coup on n'a pas les mêmes
opportunités que au lycée à l'école là
debuc comme j'ai cru comprendre mais
peut-être que au lieu de créer aussi des
nouvelles des écoles franco-allemande
peut-être qu'il faudrait aussi
s'intéresser à redorer l'image des deux
langues et peut-être par exemple enfin
moi personnellement j'ai fait allemand
en 6e et je sais que dès que je disais
que je faisais allemand les gens enfin
tout de suite on revient au même cliché
de base et c'est assez fatigant et c'est
toujours les mêmes choses qu'on a et du
coup c'est aussi en blocage et je pense
qu'il faudrait montrer d'autres images
que il y a toujours ces images de
d'ennemis voilà
qui est encore prise de parole
excusez-moi ça marche donc bonjour à
tous moi je viens aussi de du lycée
Maurice Ravel et en fait je me suis
retrouvé ici grâce à un énorme cocktail
de chance c'est c'est grâce à ma mère en
fait qui m'a parlé de l'Allemagne quand
j'étais très jeune et qui m'a donné qui
m'a donné son amour pour le pays et donc
moi je pense que j'ai choisi cette
filière évidemment puisque je j'aimais
déjà la langue de la culture mais que
c'est quelque chose qui se transmet
peut-être pas forcément
de manière héréditaire mais mais c'est
vraiment d'un individu un autre de
parler de ses expériences on donne
l'amour qu'on ressent pour quelque chose
ça se transmet en fait
c'est ce que c'est ce que je ressens et
c'est pourquoi je suis arrivée ici
bonjour est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
vous parliez avant de redorer le blason
de la langue allemande et donc
j'aimerais bien me présenter un projet
qu'on a dans l'Académie de Strasbourg
avec le Land duberg donc pour tous mes
camarades qui viennent du lundi de
Strasbourg on a mis en place un
partenariat entre donc l'Académie
Strasbourg qui s'appelle le Conseil des
lycées en franco-allemand et donc ce
sont 20 lycées en français vin
littéralement qui travaillent ensemble
sur l'amitié franco-allemande et donc
notre but est de mettre en avant
l'apprentissage des deux langues dans
nos académies région respectives et on
travaille aussi avec donc les
organisations comme l'ophage pour
essayer de dans les écoles faire des
projets pour montrer l'importance de
l'amitié franco-allemande et la culture
de nos deux pays respectifs et donc
essayer d'encourager les jeunes
aujourd'hui à apprendre nos deux langues
merci
un peu pour rebondir ce qu'il a dit mais
oui c'est vrai que je pense que une
vraie solution c'est de mettre en place
des partenariats entre le lycée français
et allemand de toutes les régions en
France pas seulement les régions
frontalières parce que je pense que pour
que ça redevienne une langue appréciée
étudiée il faut mettre en place des
partenariats dans toutes les régions
même si pour l'instant c'est vraiment
plus les régions frontalières et je
pense que des partenaires concrets ça
permet vraiment de déjà proposer des
échanges et
oui enfin ça permet de donner envie par
je pense que par le voyage ça permet de
plus donner envie que juste si on le
présente comme une langue qui est
difficile à apprendre et qui est
difficile à étudier
et à parler et si on le présente juste
comme ça je pense que c'est plus les
clichés qui prédominent et pas la
culture et tout ce qui est en dehors de
seulement la langue donc voilà je pense
que des partenariats ce serait vraiment
utile et après c'est difficile puisque
ça vient de l'État je pense il faut
cette demande du financement et tout ça
mais si on le veut vraiment je pense que
c'est possible et je pense que c'est une
bonne solution
j'y repensé à un truc un député tout à
l'heure c'est que en fait
je pense qu'il y a peut-être une chose
sur laquelle il pourrait faire attention
aussi c'est de pas et ça reprend l'idée
du législatif et parlementaire et juste
exécutif de pas non plus faire que des
projets de pas comment dire de pas
perpétuer le lien par des projets
uniquement à la tête des états par
exemple aujourd'hui on va étendre les
liens au projet dans le spatial etc la
recherche mais aussi perpétuelle le lien
au niveau individuel et il y a une chose
simple juste qui m'est passé par
l'esprit c'est le fait que ce Parlement
franco-allemand qui a été institué en
2019 il me semble
n'est pas élu par les ni parler français
ni par les Allemands mais par des
députés français allemand ce qui fait
qu'il y a beaucoup de moyens directs et
donc moi une prise de conscience directe
voilà ce sera tout en fait ce sont les
députés de nos parlements qui sont
désignés par leurs groupes pour sierger
dans l'assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande ce ne sont pas des
députés spécifiques sont des députés de
l'Assemblée nationale et des députés du
Bundes stack donc ils sont élus par les
citoyens par définition oui juste ils
sont pas élus pour cette fonction ils
sont élus et effectivement quand on est
député on exerce un certain nombre de
fonctions et ce sont les députés après
qui qui organisent leur vie et c'est
c'est
pour une fonction à l'échelle nationale
et pour une fonction à l'échelle front
française et allemande
effectivement en tout cas ça n'enlève
pas la légitimité des députés qui
siègent eux mais j'entends bien ok
est-ce que je suis désolé on va être
obligé de conclure
nous étions vraiment ravis de pouvoir
avoir ce temps d'échange avec vous il
était un peu trop bref mais voilà dans
dans tous les événements que nous
organisons
nous essayons d'avoir un échange avec la
jeunesse et nous ne voulons pas que vous
soyez des spectateurs mais des acteurs
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il
était important pour berbal et moi de
pouvoir avoir cet échange à bâtons
rompus sans filtre qui ne soit pas
organisé pour que vous ne soyez pas que
vous ne quittiez pas cette journée en
spectateur mais que vous quittiez cette
journée en acteur et vous avez vu la
confiance que nous avons en vous pour
que vous puissiez demain continuer
à nos côtés et porté haut l'amitié
franco-allemande donc merci beaucoup
berbel je te laisse le soin de conclure
et bien je vais je vais ramener chez moi
les
suggestions très concrètes qui ont été
faites comment renforcer l'apprentissage
de la langue par des structures par des
programmes d'échange des partenariats
mais aussi par l'émotion c'est en tout
cas comme ça que j'ai compris la
contribution donc pas simplement se
contenter de dire que nous devons
travailler ensemble d'un point de vue
technique mais aussi que tout cela
vienne du coeur
de manière à ce qu'on puisse continuer à
éliminer tous les préjugés du style
homme et la langue elle est beaucoup
trop difficile mais pourquoi est-ce que
j'en aurais besoin et pourquoi je
devrais faire ça voilà donc
l'émotion va être importante et toute
façon je repars d'ici avec une grande
émotion je suis ravi que nous ayons pu
faire connaissance je vous souhaite à
tous beaucoup de chance et de réussite
et j'espère que vous continuerez à
porter cette amitié dans vos coeurs et
que vous la transmettrez à ceux qui
n'ont pas pu être aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup
et voilà donc pour ce moment de dialogue
un peu particulier entre la jeunesse
française la jeunesse allemande il
s'agissait vous l'avez vu de lycéens et
les deux présidentes du Bundestag et de
l'Assemblée nationale ils en ont des
idées c'est jeune lycéens des deux côtés
du Rhin Marco pommier qu'est-ce que vous
retenez de leur propositions concrètes
écoutez Myriam ce qu'on peut dire déjà
c'est que c'était des jeunes très
honorés de pouvoir poser leurs questions
dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale face à yelbrun pivée et face à
Bar belle base présidente du bootenstag
allemand des jeunes qui ont beaucoup
parlé des langues de l'attractivité de
l'Alma de l'allemand et du français qui
peuvent être l'élan des langues
difficiles à apprendre il y a le brum
Pivet a tenu à rappeler les centaines de
milliers d'échanges qui existent entre
les jeunes Français et les jeunes
allemands et effectivement ces jeunes et
bien ils avaient des solutions comme
créer des lycées spécifiques comme
commencer l'apprentissage de ces langues
dès la maternelle et puisqu'on peut dire
aussi Myriam c'est que ces jeunes ils
ont interrogé les deux présidentes sur
la capacité de la France à pouvoir
s'écouter à pouvoir à pouvoir coopérer
il y a LeBron Pivet leur a répondu que
le passé nous appelait à nous dépasser
que faire la paix était un acte de
courage par belle basse à elle ajouter
que nous avions beaucoup de différence
mais que nous avions aussi beaucoup de
points communs merci beaucoup Marco
pommier duplex de la salle des quatre
colonnes merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis tout au long de cette journée
particulière merci également à Valérie
Valérie Brochard oui avec deux jeunes on
ne va pas les laisser repartir sans un
mot à votre micro Valérie absolument
Myriam je suis avec deux élèves du lycée
franco-allemand de Buc près de
Versailles il y a Marie et Julian Marie
qu'est-ce que ça signifie pour toi toi
qui a 17 ans qu'est-ce que ça signifie
pour toi l'amitié franco-allemande pour
moi et pour nous même l'amitié
franco-allemande c'est c'est même pas
une amitié c'est même une famille parce
que dès que j'étais petite mon père il
est allemand ma mère elle est française
donc vraiment c'est depuis que je suis
toute petite j'ai je suis née dans cette
amitié dans cette famille
franco-allemande et j'ai grandi avec
donc je pourrais même pas m'imaginer
quelque chose d'autre que cette amitié
se couple franco-allemand et c'est pour
ça que je suis honoré vraiment d'être là
ici parce que c'est très impressionnant
de voir tous ces tous ces gens tous ces
bâtiments et c'est c'est réconfortant de
voir que cette amitié fonctionne et
merci beaucoup et toi Julian tu étais là
depuis ce matin comme tout le monde
d'ailleurs donc à la Sorbonne qu'est-ce
que tu as retenu de l'intégralité de
cette journée
j'ai trouvé ça vachement enfin on a eu
énormément de chance de d'être ici
aujourd'hui et je trouvais ça vachement
vachement plaisant de voir à quel point
on a pu assister directement et de façon
extrêmement proche à tout ce qui s'est
passé on a notamment j'ai pu assister à
être au premier rang tout de suite donc
dire bonjour à des ministres notamment
le ministre des Transports qui a pu me
serrer la main j'étais très honoré donc
c'est vrai représentent vraiment une
énorme chance de pouvoir être là
aujourd'hui parce que pour ma part ma
mère est allemande mon père est
franco-allemand donc allez de
nationalités également donc ça a
toujours été incroyable cette amitié
entre l'Allemagne et la France et pour
être là aujourd'hui et voir le président
de la République ainsi que le chancelier
c'est c'était très très honoré en tout
cas très honorable comment on dit au
revoir en allemand
Valérie merci à toutes les équipes cette
fois ça y est je vais pouvoir remercier
l'ensemble des équipes de la Chaîne
parlementaire pour cette très belle
journée de direct vive l'amitié
franco-allemande et très belle soirée à
vous restez fidèle à la chaîne
parlementaire
[Musique]